Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行在爱彼迎（Airbnb）上体验会更好。现在，你可以通过爱彼迎探索加拿大及其众多的本地隐藏宝藏。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，制作组帮我安排了住处。第二年，我就想，嘿，不管那笔制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能给我，让我自己去找个更有社区氛围的地方住，你懂吗？是的。我确实这么做了，我租了一间爱彼迎，一个小公寓，正对着公园，非常可爱。我喜欢那位房东，我在那儿住了两个月。哇。是的，而且我离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得我在那里过上了一种小生活。我在想加拿大落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和阿尔伯塔省的落基山脉。我不知道，感觉如果你在那里给自己找个舒适的小木屋，你懂我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart Hello, welcome to the second drink of the coup. We have some fun stuff for you today to kick off this episode.
好吧，听着，也许你应该考虑为你的下一次冒险选择爱彼迎。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。还有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响的优质大理石花纹肋眼牛排更棒的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到你家门口的滋滋作响的优质大理石花纹肋眼牛排。一份你甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购的优质大理石花纹肋眼牛排。无论你的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足你。下载Instacart。你好，欢迎来到《政变》的第二杯。今天我们有一些有趣的内容来开启这一集。
I'll start with a great background catch. Diego Efeo spotted this. Andy's nickname while he is playing Call of Duty is Here Comes Trouble, his acapella group. And Karen's is Karen the gym slayer. I remembered that one, but I forgot that Andy's was Here Comes Trouble. Well, we also got some mail about a scene that was added to the superfan version. Hulls06 wrote in and said, do you have any info or tidbits about Jan's visit to Stanford
我先从一个很棒的背景花絮开始。迭戈·埃菲奥（Diego Efeo）发现了这个。安迪在玩《使命召唤》时的昵称是“麻烦来了”（Here Comes Trouble），这是他的阿卡贝拉合唱团的名字。而凯伦的是“凯伦，健身房杀手”（Karen the gym slayer）。我记得那个，但我忘了安迪的是“麻烦来了”。好吧，我们还收到了一些关于超级粉丝版中增加的一个场景的邮件。Hulls06写信问，关于简（Jan）访问斯坦福（Stanford）
and the interaction with Jim regarding the meeting with Dwight? I had never seen that clip and thought it was so funny and strange. Okay, so I went and I watched the scene. It does seem like it's out of nowhere. Jan's behavior is so different. She's jokey and she clearly likes the Stamford branch better. And I wanted to read how it was in the shooting draft.
以及她与吉姆（Jim）关于德怀特（Dwight）会议的互动，你们有什么信息或花絮吗？我以前从未见过那个片段，觉得它既好笑又奇怪。好吧，所以我去看了那个场景。它看起来确实很突兀。简的行为太不同了。她很爱开玩笑，而且她显然更喜欢斯坦福分部。我想读一下拍摄剧本里是怎么写的。
I have no memory of Jan visiting Stamford. It's in the super fan version. Okay. Yeah. But here's how it was scripted. And it was in the shooting draft, so they, you know, they did shoot it. It starts with this narration. As Jim turns to Karen, he sees that he is greeting Jan, who has just entered. Jan says, Hello, Jim, how's work? Jim feels caught because they're playing Call of Duty. He says, Good. Jan casually walks over to his computer, hits some keys to explode a grenade, killing his soldier.
我对简访问斯坦福毫无印象。它在超级粉丝版里。好的。是的。但剧本是这样写的。而且它在拍摄剧本里，所以他们确实拍了。它以这段旁白开始。当吉姆转向凯伦时，他看到他正在迎接刚进来的简。简说：“你好，吉姆，工作怎么样？”吉姆感到被抓包了，因为他们正在玩《使命召唤》。他说：“很好。”简随意地走到他的电脑前，按了几下键引爆了一枚手榴弹，杀死了他的士兵。
Jan laughs, someone turns the lights back on. And then Jan says, Jim, I'm meeting with Josh now, but remind me to tell you before I go what Dwight said to me earlier. You'll get a kick out of it. And she's like all jokey. And it says she heads into the conference room, Karen smiles at Jim.
简笑了，有人把灯打开了。然后简说：“吉姆，我现在要和乔什（Josh）开会，但在我走之前提醒我告诉你德怀特之前对我说了什么。你会觉得很有趣的。”她表现得非常爱开玩笑。然后她走进会议室，凯伦对吉姆笑了笑。
And then Jim has a talking head where he says, things are a little different in Stanford. It's not so bad. Wow. Yeah. Jokey Jan. In Stanford. Who knows Call of Duty?
然后吉姆有一个独白，他说：“斯坦福的情况有点不同。还不赖。”哇。是的。爱开玩笑的简。在斯坦福。谁懂《使命召唤》？
And who like typed in some stuff and ruined Jim's game. I see what you mean. I also wanted to share some extended footage from the deleted scenes. I'll set it up for you. It would have happened at the very beginning of the cold open. It's about movie Monday.
而且还像那样敲了几下键盘，毁了吉姆的游戏。我明白你的意思了。我还想分享一些来自删除片段的加长镜头。我先为你铺垫一下。它本应发生在冷开场的最开始。是关于电影星期一的。
And Michael has gathered everyone in the conference room, but there is someone missing. We discussed this a little bit in our breakdown, but there is one person who refuses to attend. Do you know who it is? Is it Stanley? Let's hear it and you'll find out. Let's go. Let's go, let's go, let's go! Let's go! Everybody here? Yes. Where's Angela?
迈克尔（Michael）把大家都召集到了会议室，但有一个人缺席了。我们在之前的分析中讨论过一点，但有一个人拒绝参加。你知道是谁吗？是斯坦利（Stanley）吗？让我们听听看，你就会知道了。走吧。走吧，走吧，走吧！走吧！大家都到了吗？是的。安吉拉（Angela）在哪儿？
Where's Angela? No, not everyone approves of Movie Monday. I won't say who. I don't approve. I don't. Dwight. Oh it's you. It's me. Well I have to imagine pretty much any movie Michael would choose, Angela would not be a fan. No and also it just goes to her rule following. Like what are we doing? Are we working today or are we watching a movie? Yes. Well, we also got a lot of mail because this is the episode with the Crentus scene. Mm-hmm.
安吉拉在哪儿？不，不是每个人都赞成电影星期一。我不会说是谁。我不赞成。我不赞成。德怀特。哦，是你。是我。好吧，我不得不想象迈克尔选择的几乎任何电影，安吉拉都不会是粉丝。不，而且这也符合她遵守规则的性格。就像我们在做什么？我们今天是在工作还是在看电影？是的。好吧，我们还收到了很多邮件，因为这一集有“克伦特斯”（Crentus）场景。嗯哼。
Ugh. One of my favorites. And we got this letter that made me chuckle from Lee B, who said, I had a pain management doctor named. I know, I know, it's so funny. I can't even say it. Named. It's so ridiculous.
呃。我最喜欢的场景之一。我们收到了这封让我忍俊不禁的信，来自李·B（Lee B），他说：“我有一位疼痛管理医生叫……我知道，我知道，这太好笑了。我甚至说不出来。叫……这太荒谬了。”
It is the same as Crentus the dentist. Okay, Lee's pain management doctor's name was, I can't get it out, it was Dr. Bochter. That's so silly. Dr. Bochter. Lee said I heard this scene in my head every time I had an appointment. I don't know how I could not have Dr. Bochter as my doctor. I couldn't. Dr. Bochter.
这和克伦特斯牙医的名字一样。好吧，李的疼痛管理医生的名字是……我实在说不出口，是博克特医生（Dr. Bochter）。太傻了。博克特医生。李说，每次我有预约时，我脑子里都会浮现出这个场景。我不知道我怎么能不让博克特医生当我的医生。我做不到。博克特医生。你能吗？
Could you? No, it's too funnyter as my doctor. I couldn't. Dr. Bokter. Could you? No, it's too funny. Oh my goodness. Well, lastly, I thought we could wrap up with a candy bag alt. It was a Creed talking head about Dwight and Angela's Macbeth-like storyline in this episode. And it read like this.
不，这太好笑了。博克特医生。你能吗？不，这太好笑了。天哪。好吧，最后，我想我们可以用一个糖果袋的替代方案来结束。那是克里德（Creed）关于德怀特和安吉拉在这一集中麦克白式故事情节的独白。它是这样写的。
Creed says, I'll bet the blonde girl loves this. She's been sleeping with Dwight for, oh, I'd say about a year now. Oh my goodness! So I think they were really debating on who's gonna out Dwight and Angela. Yes! And they played around with maybe the idea
克里德说：“我敢打赌那个金发女孩喜欢这个。她和德怀特睡了，哦，我想大概有一年了。”天哪！所以我认为他们当时真的在争论谁会揭发德怀特和安吉拉。是的！他们确实考虑过
of it being Creed in this episode. Wow, I love it! There you have it. And now here is our breakdown of the coup. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends.
让克里德在这一集中揭发。哇，我喜欢！就是这样。现在是我们的《政变》分析。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Are you ready for some conniving and some backstabbing? It's the coup. It's a little bit Macbethy. I think that's a term. Look it up, Macbethy. Season three, episode three, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Greg Daniels. You know what I would really love? What? A summary! Guess what Angela? I have a summary! By the way, why did I say that almost like Cookie Monster? A summary! Here is my summary. It's a
现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。你准备好迎接一些勾心斗角和背后捅刀了吗？这就是《政变》。这有点麦克白风格。我想这是一个术语。查一下，麦克白风格。第三季第三集，由保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）导演。你知道我真的很想要什么吗？什么？总结！猜猜怎么着，安吉拉？我有一个总结！顺便说一句，为什么我刚才说得那么像饼干怪兽？总结！这是我的总结。它有点
little bit like Stacy. Oh it is. It's some Stacey undertones. We're all Kevin. It's a little Cookie Monster mixed with Kevin. Here's my summary. Michael gets into hot water with Jan after she catches him throwing a movie Monday in the office neglecting work. So, egged on by Angela, aka Lady Macbeth, she convinces Dwight to undermine Michael by meeting up with Jan in an attempt to steal the manager position. You're gonna see a whole new side of Steve Carell that is amazing in this episode. At the same time, Kelly convinces Pam to have a... Fashion show. Fashion show. Fashion show. At lunch. Fastback number one.
像史黛西（Stacy）。哦，确实。它带有一些史黛西的色彩。我们都是凯文（Kevin）。这有点像饼干怪兽混合了凯文。这是我的总结。迈克尔在简抓到他在办公室举办电影星期一而忽视工作后陷入了困境。所以，在安吉拉（也就是麦克白夫人）的怂恿下，她劝说德怀特通过与简会面来破坏迈克尔，试图窃取经理职位。在这一集中，你会看到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）全新的一面，非常精彩。与此同时，凯莉（Kelly）说服帕姆（Pam）举办一场……时装秀。时装秀。时装秀。在午餐时间。快讯第一条。
So this is a very, very big Rainn Wilson, Dwight, Angela, Michael episode. Wouldn't you say this is like, the three of you, Angela, Michael episode. Wouldn't you say? This is like the three of you are really driving this episode. I mean, we have this weird love triangle, if you will. I feel like. Yes. I mean, it's true.
所以这是一集非常非常重头的雷恩·威尔森（Rainn Wilson）、德怀特、安吉拉、迈克尔的剧集。你难道不觉得这是你们三个人的剧集吗？你难道不觉得吗？这就像你们三个人在真正推动这一集。我是说，我们有这个奇怪的三角恋，如果你愿意这么说的话。我觉得。是的。我是说，这是真的。
I feel like I'm in love with Dwight. He's in love with Michael. Yeah. It's weird. Well, we really wanted Rainn Wilson to come on the podcast this week, and Rainn Wilson wanted to come on the podcast this week. But guess what? If you can believe it, we had some technical issues that kept us from being able to make
我觉得我爱上了德怀特。他爱上了迈克尔。是的。这很奇怪。好吧，我们真的很想让雷恩·威尔森这周来参加播客，雷恩·威尔森也想来参加播客。但你猜怎么着？如果你能相信的话，我们遇到了一些技术问题，导致我们无法实现
that happen. However, Rainn Wilson did send in some audio clips, and we're going to sprinkle those in throughout. So he will be making an appearance. Although very soon, he will be making an appearance, although very soon he will be making like an appearance appearance. I'm so bummed about the dang wi-fi of it all. You guys, it gets glitchy. It gets glitchy up in here. I don't know. What am I even talking like? Am I 21 in the club? What am I doing? Glitchy up in here? Oh baby that's not 21 in the
这一点。不过，雷恩·威尔森确实发来了一些音频片段，我们将把它们穿插在整个节目中。所以他会露面。虽然很快，他会露面，虽然很快他就会真正地露面。我对该死的Wi-Fi感到非常沮丧。伙计们，它变得不稳定了。这里变得不稳定了。我不知道。我甚至在说什么？我是21岁在夜店吗？我在做什么？这里不稳定？哦宝贝，那不是21岁在
club. It's not. I mean I hope it's not. Is it? It's getting glitchy up. You think when you're 21 in the club you talk about glitchy Wi-Fi? Glitchy up in here? That could be your undies in a wad. It could be anything. Alright. You know what I'm saying? Glitchy up in here could mean a lot of things, but apparently when you're 48 in your converted tough shed that you made into an office, you say, is glitchy up in here? We are so sorry that it's hashtag glitchy up in here, but we're going to figure it out. We're going to figure it out. So listen, my fast fact number one is that even though this episode is the love triangle of Michael Dwight and
夜店。不是。我是说我希望不是。是吗？这里变得不稳定了。你以为当你21岁在夜店时会谈论不稳定的Wi-Fi吗？这里不稳定？那可能是你心烦意乱了。可能是任何事情。好吧。你懂我的意思吗？“这里不稳定”可能意味着很多事情，但显然当你48岁，坐在你改造成办公室的坚固棚屋里时，你会说，这里不稳定吗？我们非常抱歉，这是标签“这里不稳定”，但我们会解决它的。我们会解决它的。所以听着，我的快讯第一条是，尽管这一集是迈克尔、德怀特和
Angela, there was a big internet stir as the kids would say. Do they say that? Do they say there's a stir? Pretty much. Pretty much you and I have our finger on the pulse of the hip lingo. Do they say the internet was a stir? The internet was a stir with the fact that this episode has the first Jim Caron flirt. Oh, oh I know.
安吉拉的三角恋，但正如孩子们所说，互联网上引起了轩然大波。他们是这么说的吗？他们说引起了轩然大波吗？差不多。差不多，你和我都掌握了时髦的行话。他们说互联网引起了轩然大波吗？互联网上因为这一集有第一次吉姆和凯伦的调情而引起了轩然大波。哦，哦，我知道。
Oh Angela, the internet was a buzz. Was it a buzz? Well, you know what? I like the internet was a stir. All right. That's what I'm gonna say now. It's glitchy up in here and the internet was a stir about it.
哦，安吉拉，互联网上沸腾了。是沸腾了吗？好吧，你知道吗？我喜欢“互联网引起了轩然大波”。好吧。我现在要这么说。这里不稳定，互联网上引起了轩然大波。
Oh doll face. Oh doll face. So yes, the flirt begins. The distance between Jim and Pam is growing. They are not in touch. Even though Jim does bring Pam up a couple of times in this episode, the message boards blew up. Do you remember that after this episode came out?
哦，洋娃娃。哦，洋娃娃。所以是的，调情开始了。吉姆和帕姆之间的距离正在拉大。他们没有联系。尽管吉姆在这一集中确实提到了几次帕姆，但留言板炸开了锅。你还记得这一集播出后吗？
A lot of strong feelings. A lot of strong feelings about Jim and Karen. Poor Rashida, she was like, Rashida was like, I'm gonna go into hiding. People hate me. Except that she's so cute in this episode. She's so stinking cute. And you know what?
很多强烈的感受。关于吉姆和凯伦的很多强烈感受。可怜的拉什达（Rashida），她当时就像，拉什达就像，我要躲起来了。人们讨厌我。除了她在这一集中非常可爱。她可爱得要命。而且你知道吗？
She doesn't know about Pam. It's not her fault. That's right. People always- She's not doing anything wrong. People are like just hating on Karen but it's not Karen. Karen's not doing anything wrong. Yeah I mean do you think Jim ever told Karen about Pam? Probably not. Why would he bring that up? Why would he bring that up? Also for some weird reason the only person Jim ever really confides into is Michael. Yeah. No, he did not tell Karen about Pam. No way. All right. Well, this is leading me into fast fact. Number two, Angela, you have a fast fact for us today about Karen.
她不知道帕姆的事。这不是她的错。没错。人们总是——她没做错任何事。人们就像是在讨厌凯伦，但那不是凯伦。凯伦没做错任何事。是的，我是说你认为吉姆告诉过凯伦关于帕姆的事吗？可能没有。他为什么要提起那个？他为什么要提起那个？而且出于某种奇怪的原因，吉姆唯一真正信任的人是迈克尔。是的。不，他没有告诉凯伦关于帕姆的事。绝不可能。好吧。好吧，这引出了我的快讯第二条，安吉拉，你今天有一个关于凯伦的快讯给我们。
I do. I have a fast fact about Karen. So Karen's name, Karen Filippelli, was based off an NBC exec named Rachel Filippelli. And this is just a classic Greg Daniels move that he loved to use people's names that he actually knew. I feel like all of our writers would probably pitch names of people they already knew, but Rachel Filippelli was an exec
我有。我有一个关于凯伦的快讯。所以凯伦的名字，凯伦·菲利佩利（Karen Filippelli），是基于一位名叫瑞秋·菲利佩利（Rachel Filippelli）的NBC高管。这只是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的一个经典举动，他喜欢使用他真正认识的人的名字。我觉得我们所有的编剧可能都会推荐他们已经认识的人的名字，但瑞秋·菲利佩利是一位高管，
and Rashida said she actually met her. So Karen Filippelli was based off Rachel Filippelli was an exec and Rashida said she actually met her. So Karen Filippelli was based off Rachel Filippelli. Greg did that all the time. Mm-hmm. If you knew Greg, you better bet your name is going to end up in one of his shows. Also part of fast fact too, Jenna. I don't know if you remember this, but Rashida would sometimes spill things on set and she got the nickname of Spill-a-Pelly.
拉什达说她确实见过她。所以凯伦·菲利佩利是基于瑞秋·菲利佩利，她是一位高管，拉什达说她确实见过她。所以凯伦·菲利佩利是基于瑞秋·菲利佩利。格雷格总是那样做。嗯哼。如果你认识格雷格，你最好打赌你的名字会出现在他的节目中。也是快讯第二条的一部分，珍娜。我不知道你是否还记得，但拉什达有时会在片场洒东西，她得到了“洒洒佩利”（Spill-a-Pelly）的绰号。
I don't remember that. Spill-a-Pelly. Oh, that's amazing. That's amazing. All right. I'm going to move us to fast fact number three, because this is a huge fast fact. Angela, I don't know if it's that people are spending a lot of time at home, but this week we got a lot of mail from people that was very long, very involved, a lot of deep dives, a lot of conspiracies, and I'm gonna go into this conspiracy sent in by Susie Kowalski. This is the Jim Halpert sleeve conspiracy. You got my attention, Susie. Here is what Susie says. Guys, I took a deep dive on Jim's sleeves, as you have done on Kelly's hair and shirts.
我不记得那个了。洒洒佩利。哦，那太棒了。那太棒了。好吧。我要带我们进入快讯第三条，因为这是一个巨大的快讯。安吉拉，我不知道是不是因为人们在家里待的时间太长了，但这周我们收到了很多来自人们的邮件，非常长，非常复杂，有很多深入的研究，很多阴谋论，我要深入探讨这个由苏西·科瓦尔斯基（Susie Kowalski）寄来的阴谋论。这是吉姆·哈珀特（Jim Halpert）袖子阴谋论。你引起了我的注意，苏西。这是苏西说的。伙计们，我深入研究了吉姆的袖子，就像你们研究凯莉的头发和衬衫一样。
Someone please tell me why for all of season three, Jim's sleeves are not rolled up. He is famously known for rolling up his sleeves, yet in season three they are not rolled and he is even sometimes wearing a blazer. Here's what Suzy says, I believe it's love stay with me for a second. Oh she wrote stay with me for a second. Go on. She says, Jim's iconic look is him with his dress shirt sleeves rolled up and never wearing a blazer, even though the rest of the men in the office do. However, when Jim moves to Stanford,
有人请告诉我为什么整个第三季，吉姆的袖子都没有卷起来。他以卷起袖子而闻名，然而在第三季它们没有卷起来，他甚至有时穿着西装外套。这是苏西说的，我相信这是爱情，跟我待一会儿。哦，她写了“跟我待一会儿”。继续。她说，吉姆的标志性造型是他穿着礼服衬衫，袖子卷起来，从不穿西装外套，尽管办公室里的其他男人都穿。然而，当吉姆搬到斯坦福时，
he's either wearing his blazer or his dress shirt with his sleeves not rolled up, which is weird because also Andy does not wear a blazer. But after the merger, Andy wears a blazer every day in Scranton. Oh, Suzy. Oh, Suzy. All right, Suzy also says, this is also seen in season three, episode three and four, not two because that's the convention,
他要么穿着西装外套，要么穿着袖子没卷起来的礼服衬衫，这很奇怪，因为安迪也不穿西装外套。但在合并之后，安迪在斯克兰顿（Scranton）每天都穿西装外套。哦，苏西。哦，苏西。好吧，苏西还说，这在第三季第三集和第四集也看到了，不是第二集，因为那是大会，
five, six, seven, and eight. Eight is the merger, where Andy suddenly starts wearing a blazer all the time, and Jim keeps not rolling his sleeves. But since he's quote unquote home now, you would think he would go back to his old ways, but he doesn't. It's not fancy Stanford, Angela. It's not.
五、六、七和八。八是合并，安迪突然开始一直穿西装外套，而吉姆一直不卷袖子。但既然他现在“回家”了，你会以为他会回到老样子，但他没有。这不是时髦的斯坦福，安吉拉。不是。
He keeps not rolling his sleeves even when he gets back to Scranton. She says, even in episodes 9, 10, and 11, even when in 11 he's in the warehouse handing Karen the lease he's back in a blazer. But why? It continues in episodes 12 through 21, not 22 because that's beach day, and episode 23. Guess what? Season four, episode one, no blazer, his sleeves are rolled up. I repeat, the sleeves are rolled up, people.
他一直不卷袖子，即使他回到斯克兰顿。她说，即使在第9、10和11集，即使在第11集他在仓库把租约交给凯伦时，他又穿上了西装外套。但为什么？这在第12到21集继续，不是22集，因为那是海滩日，还有第23集。你猜怎么着？第四季第一集，没有西装外套，他的袖子卷起来了。我重复一遍，袖子卷起来了，伙计们。
Jim is back, baby. And this is her conclusion. I believe Jim's sleeves are directly correlated with his dating of Karen and not dating Pam. I think when he moved to Connecticut, the sleeves were his way of starting a new chapter. Maybe it's symbolic that he was never comfortable with Karen, he couldn't be his real self
吉姆回来了，宝贝。这就是她的结论。我相信吉姆的袖子与他与凯伦的约会以及不与帕姆约会直接相关。我认为当他搬到康涅狄格州时，袖子是他开启新篇章的方式。也许这象征着他从未对凯伦感到自在，他无法做真实的自己
and roll up his sleeves. But in season four, episode one's cold open, he's comfortable again, he rolls up his sleeves, and we know at this point he's comfortable again. He rolls up his sleeves. And we know at this point, he's dating Pam. Let's give her a clap. CLAPPING Suzie, that is some serious sleeve tracking. I applaud you on your attention to detail.
并卷起袖子。但在第四季第一集的冷开场中，他又感到自在了，他卷起了袖子，我们知道在这一点上他又感到自在了。他卷起了袖子。我们知道在这一点上，他在和帕姆约会。让我们给她鼓掌。鼓掌。苏西，那是相当认真的袖子追踪。我为你对细节的关注鼓掌。
Suzie asked if this was intentional or an accident. Suzie, this was intentional. Suzy, I'm telling you, you are making some ladies in wardrobe really, really happy. They did a lot of things like that. They would change our wardrobe depending on what our characters were going through. And wow, Suzy, I am so impressed.
苏西问这是故意的还是意外。苏西，这是故意的。苏西，我告诉你，你让服装组的一些女士非常非常高兴。她们做了很多这样的事情。她们会根据我们角色所经历的事情来改变我们的服装。哇，苏西，我印象太深刻了。
You're going to see a lot of moments from Pam where her wardrobe changes or her hair changes because of you know who she's dating or what she's up to. Some work, some don't. You know we do that in life right? We try on new looks. They're not all winners guys. They're not all winners. Well listen you know we're all stuck inside. We're wondering what are we going to do? Maybe something you could do is rewatch season three of The Office and look at Jim's sleeves. See what Suzy saw.
你会看到帕姆的很多时刻，她的服装会改变，或者她的头发会改变，因为你知道她和谁约会或者她在做什么。有些有效，有些无效。你知道我们在生活中也会那样做，对吧？我们尝试新造型。它们并不都是赢家，伙计们。它们并不都是赢家。好吧，听着，你知道我们都被困在里面了。我们想知道我们要做什么？也许你可以做的一件事是重温《办公室》第三季，看看吉姆的袖子。看看苏西看到了什么。
Let me tell you something, Suzy, from here out, I'm going to be looking at his sleeves. So, yeah. All right. Fantastic. Fast facts, lady. All right, guys, we're going to take a break. And when we come back, we're're gonna break down the coup and get ready for some sweet audio clips from Mr. Rainn Wilson. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where like in order to trick men into taking care of themselves they made a medical clinic that
让我告诉你一件事，苏西，从现在开始，我会盯着他的袖子看。所以，是的。好吧。太棒了。快讯，女士。好吧，伙计们，我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们要剖析《政变》，并准备好迎接来自雷恩·威尔森先生的甜蜜音频片段。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。女士，你看到那个关于男性健康和心理健康的搞笑《周六夜现场》小品了吗？为了诱骗男性照顾自己，他们建立了一个医疗诊所，
is like a podcast like a dude bro podcast. Oh my gosh it's so funny but it's also because it's kind of true. Men are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you. Six million men in the US suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed. So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world, we would like to encourage you to talk to someone.
就像一个播客，一个兄弟播客。天哪，太搞笑了，但这也是因为它有点真实。男性通常不愿意花时间去深入了解他们的心理健康。我有一个统计数据给你。美国每年有600万男性患有抑郁症，而且通常未被诊断。所以听着，如果你是一个男人，你感到世界的重压，我们想鼓励你和某人谈谈。
A friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you wanna give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies.
朋友、爱人、治疗师。也许你想试试BetterHelp。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供接触具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。和BetterHelp谈谈吧。我们的听众在BetterHelp.com/officeladies首次订购可享受10%的折扣。
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. The Hot Honey McRispy is so back at McDonald's. With juicy 100% Canadian-raised seasoned chicken, shredded lettuce, crispy jalapenos, and that completely craveable hot honey sauce, it's a sweet heat repeat you don't want to miss. Get your Hot Honey McRisbee today. Available for a limited time, only at McDonald's. Okay, we're back. We've got our cold open. only at McDonald's. Okay, we're back.
那是BetterHelp，H-E-L-P点com斜杠officeladies。Hot Honey McRispy在麦当劳回归了。配上多汁的100%加拿大饲养调味鸡肉、切碎的生菜、脆皮墨西哥辣椒和那种完全令人垂涎的辣蜂蜜酱，这是一种你不想错过的甜蜜热辣重复。今天就来买你的Hot Honey McRisbee。限时供应，仅在麦当劳。好的，我们回来了。我们有我们的冷开场。仅在麦当劳。好的，我们回来了。
We've got our cold open. Michael and Pam are popping some popcorn in the microwave because guess what? It's Movie Monday. I guess that means we find out in this episode that Michael makes everybody go in and watch a movie or maybe a medical video or maybe an episode of Entourage. I have to tell you at 42 seconds, Jenna, your look to camera when you said that they ran out of like instructional videos, then you watched a medical video, your pause and look
我们有我们的冷开场。迈克尔和帕姆在微波炉里爆爆米花，因为你猜怎么着？是电影星期一。我想这意味着我们在这一集中发现迈克尔让每个人都进去看电影，或者可能是医疗视频，或者可能是《明星伙伴》（Entourage）的一集。我必须告诉你，在42秒时，珍娜，当你提到他们用完了教学视频，然后你看了医疗视频时，你对镜头的表情，你的停顿和看
to camera is absolute genius. Oh, lady. It was so good. You know, we got a lot of mail of people asking, why did I pause and look at camera? Because he made you watch a medical video. OK, I rewatched this with my daughter, and she was like, mom, what's the deal with the medical video?
镜头的表情绝对是天才。哦，女士。太棒了。你知道，我们收到了很多邮件，人们问，为什么我停顿并看镜头？因为他让你看医疗视频。好的，我和我女儿重温了这一集，她就像，妈妈，那个医疗视频是怎么回事？
I was like, imagine they ran out of videos related to paper supply or work-related videos, and then he just found one on how do you give someone a root canal and you had to watch that. She was like, ugh. And I was like, exactly. Exactly.
我当时就像，想象一下他们用完了与纸张供应或工作相关视频，然后他只是找到了一个关于如何给某人做根管治疗的视频，你不得不看那个。她就像，呃。我当时就像，没错。没错。
Also, that look to camera that you're talking about, that is in the script. In the script, it says Pam looks at, gives camera a look, like, can you believe it? Oh my Lord, it was so good. Well, you know, Michael says this is the only cure for the Monday blues. And then he goes into his cabinet, lady. At 13 seconds, he goes into his cabinet, into his safe, to get a copy of Varsity Blues. Do we need to revisit all of the things in his cabinet? You know, I saw Pringles, I saw the rubber chicken that has to be in the safe.
而且，你谈到的那个看镜头的表情，是在剧本里的。在剧本里，它写着帕姆看镜头，给镜头一个表情，就像，你能相信吗？哦，天哪，太棒了。好吧，你知道，迈克尔说这是周一忧郁症的唯一解药。然后他走进他的柜子，女士。在13秒时，他走进他的柜子，走进他的保险箱，去拿一份《校园蓝调》（Varsity Blues）。我们需要重温他柜子里的所有东西吗？你知道，我看到了品客薯片，我看到了必须在保险箱里的橡胶鸡。
You know? Yeah. There's a blue pack of gum. Mm-hmm. Here's the thing. His silver tea set that was in there during Dwight's speech. Where did it go? I don't know. He had to move it for his movie stash. There's more than one movie in there. There's also a new photo of Jan taped over the old photo.
你知道吗？是的。有一包蓝色的口香糖。嗯哼。事情是这样的。德怀特演讲时在里面的银茶具。它去哪儿了？我不知道。他不得不为他的电影储备挪动它。里面不止一部电影。还有一张简的新照片贴在旧照片上。
The old photo was a picture of Jan from a newsletter when her last name was still Levinson Gold. And now there's some other photo. But I couldn't catch it exactly what it was. I like to think that it's a photo he took of her that she didn't want him to take. Oh, 100%. Well, I have a little something about this cold open. Sam, will you play Mustang? What's going on? And now it's time for Kinsey Tidbit. Hey, look who got her kids in on it.
旧照片是简在时事通讯里的一张照片，当时她的姓还是莱文森·戈尔德（Levinson Gold）。现在有另一张照片。但我没能看清它到底是什么。我喜欢认为那是他拍的她不想让他拍的照片。哦，100%。好吧，关于这个冷开场我有一点小东西。萨姆，你能播放野马吗？怎么了？现在是金赛花絮时间。嘿，看谁让她的孩子们参与进来了。
All three of them. We had to make a sentence so they could all have an equal amount of time so it was fair. You guys know how it is. With multiple children, it all has to be fair or somebody gets their feelings hurt. We got a Kinsey tidbit. I have a Kinsey tidbit about this cold open. Jenna Fischer, did you know that in 1999, I auditioned for Varsity Blues? What? Oh yeah.
三个都参与了。我们必须造一个句子，这样他们才能有相等的时间，这样才公平。你们知道是怎么回事。有多个孩子，一切都必须公平，否则某人的感情会受伤。我们有一个金赛花絮。我有一个关于这个冷开场的金赛花絮。珍娜·费舍尔，你知道吗，1999年，我为《校园蓝调》试镜了？什么？哦，是的。
What? I did. I auditioned for the part that Allie Larder got of Darcy Spears, the cheerleading captain. She was known famously in this movie as the character who comes out in a whipped cream bikini. Oh my gosh. Whipped cream bikini to Mox, who was played by James Van Der Beek. Yeah, she seduces him in a whipped cream bikini. That's the role I auditioned for. I did not get it. So there you go. Lady,
什么？我试镜了。我试镜了艾丽·拉特（Allie Larder）得到的达西·斯皮尔斯（Darcy Spears）的角色，啦啦队长队长。她在电影里以那个穿着鲜奶油比基尼出来的角色而闻名。天哪。穿着鲜奶油比基尼给莫克斯（Mox）看，莫克斯由詹姆斯·范德比克（James Van Der Beek）饰演。是的，她穿着鲜奶油比基尼诱惑他。那就是我试镜的角色。我没得到它。所以就是这样。女士，
I have questions. Yeah, go. Did you have to do any cheerleading as part of your audition? Or the fact that you had been a cheerleader, was that a plus? Did it come up in your audition? It came up in my audition, yes, that I had had cheerleading experience. I think it's probably I was such a like unknown nobody.
我有问题。是的，说吧。你必须作为试镜的一部分做啦啦队表演吗？或者你曾经是啦啦队长的事实是一个加分项？它在你的试镜中提到了吗？它在我的试镜中提到了，是的，我有啦啦队经验。我想这可能是因为我是一个无名小卒。
I think it's probably how I got the audition because I could imagine my agent at the time who was like she's from Texas because it takes place in Texas she's blonde she was a cheerleader yeah I got the audition and I had like my Texas accent everything I did not get the part it's okay but I had read the sides and I remember being like whipped cream bikini. How does that stay on? How does that work and This movie varsity blues I had to go see it because I had to see you know the role I didn't get and there are so many things that if
我想这可能是我得到试镜的原因，因为我可以想象我当时的经纪人，他就像，她是德克萨斯人，因为它发生在德克萨斯，她是金发，她是啦啦队长，是的，我得到了试镜，我甚至有我的德克萨斯口音，我做的一切，我没得到那个角色，没关系，但我读了剧本，我记得当时就像，鲜奶油比基尼。那怎么粘得住？那是怎么运作的？这部电影《校园蓝调》，我不得不去看，因为我必须看，你知道，我没得到的角色，有很多事情，如果
You're from Texas. You're like, okay, whatever. That's a that's a bit much But one of my favorite lines that my friends and I used to say to each other was by James Van Der Beek in his Southern accent. As the character mocks, he gets into a fight with the football coach who's played by John Voight. They had some like big names in this movie. And he looks at him and goes,
你来自德克萨斯。你会觉得，好吧，随便吧。那有点过分了。但我最喜欢的台词之一，我和朋友们过去常对彼此说的，是詹姆斯·范德比克用他的南方口音说的。作为莫克斯这个角色，他和约翰·沃伊特（John Voight）饰演的橄榄球教练打了一架。他们在这部电影里有一些大牌。他看着他说，
I don't want your life. Yeah, we would say it to each other all the time. All the time. Hey, what's up? I don't want your life. Yeah, we would say it to each other all the time, all the time. Hey, what's up? I don't want your life. Okay, all right. Relax. How did you feel when you did not get the part?
我不想要你的生活。是的，我们一直对彼此说。一直。嘿，怎么了？我不想要你的生活。是的，我们一直对彼此说，一直。嘿，怎么了？我不想要你的生活。好的，好吧。放松。当你没得到那个角色时，你感觉如何？
Were you super bummed or were you relieved that you didn't have to wear a whipped cream bikini or both? Was it a mix? I think it was a mix. It was a mix. I was like, oh, I think this is gonna be a big movie, you know? Yeah. And I never got to- This is a game, that would a mix. I was like, oh, I think this is gonna be a big movie, you know? Like, and I never got to-
你是超级沮丧，还是因为不用穿鲜奶油比基尼而感到如释重负，或者两者都有？是混合的吗？我想是混合的。是混合的。我当时就像，哦，我想这会是一部大电影，你知道吗？是的。我从来没能——这是一个游戏，那会是混合的。我当时就像，哦，我想这会是一部大电影，你知道吗？就像，我从来没能——
This is a game, that would have been a game changer. Game changer, I never got to audition for movies. I was just really just going in on commercials. That was my big success is I had, you know, done a commercial about potato chips that gave you anal leakage. So, you know, this would have been a big deal. Pretty much on camera, all I had said was, wow, and then took a bite of a potato chip.
这是一个游戏，那会是一个转折点。转折点，我从来没能为电影试镜。我只是真的在试镜广告。那是我的巨大成功，我，你知道，拍了一个关于薯片的广告，让你肛门渗漏。所以，你知道，这会是一件大事。在镜头前，我所说的基本上只是，哇，然后咬了一口薯片。
So it was it was a really big deal. But I didn't get it. And that's OK. And that is my Kinsey tidbit from the cold open. I love your Kinsey tidbit. I thought that was very, very good Kinsey tidbit. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. We also had a fan question about this cold open Angela.
所以这是一件非常大的事。但我没得到它。没关系。这就是我关于冷开场的金赛花絮。我喜欢你的金赛花絮。我觉得那是非常非常好的金赛花絮。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。我们还有一个关于这个冷开场的粉丝问题，安吉拉。
We had a lot of people ask, what did we do with all the extra popcorn? Because Pam pops a bunch of popcorn and then no one takes it. You guys, we ate it. And we also just put it out on the snack table for the crew. We did eat all that popcorn. It was great. I'll never forget it. Yeah, we were excited about popcorn. We had a lot of snacks all the time, but all of our snacks, they had to be very quiet snacks because the snack table was behind the walls of the set.
我们有很多人问，我们怎么处理所有多余的爆米花？因为帕姆爆了一堆爆米花，然后没人吃。伙计们，我们吃了它。而且我们还把它放在零食桌上给工作人员。我们确实吃了所有那些爆米花。太棒了。我永远不会忘记它。是的，我们对爆米花很兴奋。我们一直有很多零食，但我们所有的零食，它们必须是非常安静的零食，因为零食桌在布景墙后面。
So our crafty people, they couldn't pop microwave popcorn because we were shooting and it would make noise. Remember we had that one cappuccino machine for like a hot second Angela, but it was so loud and it kept ruining takes because people would go back and fix themselves like a frothy cappuccino while we were trying to shoot and they were like, get that machine out of here. So this was, I mean, to say we were tickled to have some like microwave popcorn,
所以我们的工艺人员，他们不能爆微波炉爆米花，因为我们在拍摄，它会制造噪音。记得我们有那台卡布奇诺机，大概用了一小会儿，安吉拉，但它太吵了，它一直毁掉拍摄，因为人们会回去给自己弄一杯泡沫卡布奇诺，而我们正试图拍摄，他们就像，把那台机器弄出去。所以这，我是说，说我们很高兴有微波炉爆米花，
we actually really were because it was usually all things that made no noise. Yeah, like a lot of our snacks were like cheese. Lot of cheese. Lot of cheese. Guys, don't worry, Angela did not string it. Who had time for it? I don't have time for that. So I guess Pam also shares that they watched an episode of Entourage six times.
我们实际上真的很开心，因为它通常都是不制造噪音的东西。是的，就像我们很多零食都是奶酪。很多奶酪。很多奶酪。伙计们，别担心，安吉拉没有串它。谁有时间做那个？我没时间做那个。所以我猜帕姆也分享说他们看了六遍《明星伙伴》的一集。
Yeah. Which episode? I wish we knew. But Jenna, did you know that our lovable curmudgeon, Rainn Wilson, was a guest star on Entourage? No, he was not. Oh, yeah, he was. Rainn, this delighted me so much. Rainn was in season two, episode nine. The episode is called I Love You Too. He played R.J. Spencer, who was an internet comic expert. And he interviews Vincent Chase at basically the San Diego Comic-Con because get this, Vincent just got the big role of Aquaman. Okay? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. And so R.J. Spencer is going to interview him. But during the interview, Jenna, he starts talking about, I heard that you were engaged
是的。哪一集？我希望我们知道。但珍娜，你知道我们可爱的老顽固，雷恩·威尔森，是《明星伙伴》的客串明星吗？不，他不是。哦，是的，他是。雷恩，这让我太高兴了。雷恩在第二季第九集。那一集叫《我也爱你》（I Love You Too）。他饰演R.J.斯宾塞（R.J. Spencer），一位互联网漫画专家。他在圣地亚哥动漫展上采访了文森特·蔡斯（Vincent Chase），因为听着，文森特刚得到了海王（Aquaman）的大角色。好的？哦，是的。哦，是的。所以R.J.斯宾塞要采访他。但在采访中，珍娜，他开始谈论，我听说你和
to Mandy Moore and she broke up with you. You know, and guess what? This pisses Vincent off. This calls him an a hole. This is not the interview he was expecting. No and he calls him an a-hole and he storms off and RJ is like I will ruin you. I will write horrible reviews of Aquaman. You know you had your chance and I'm going to destroy you on the internet. Okay so now E, Vincent's manager right? Yeah. He's got to fix this. He's like, what do you want? You know, he's like trying to bribe them. What happens? RJ says, I want $350,000
曼迪·摩尔（Mandy Moore）订婚了，她和你分手了。你知道，你猜怎么着？这让文森特很生气。这称他为混蛋。这不是他预期的采访。不，他称他为混蛋，他冲了出去，R.J.就像，我会毁了你。我会写关于海王的恐怖评论。你知道你错过了机会，我会在互联网上摧毁你。好的，所以现在E，文森特的经理，对吧？是的。他必须解决这个问题。他就像，你想要什么？你知道，他就像试图贿赂他们。发生了什么？R.J.说，我想要35万美元
or I'm gonna destroy Aquaman online. So, meanwhile, Johnny Drama is at Comic-Con and he has a really good friend, an adult film star, Jesse Jane, played by Jessie Jane. She's promoting her fake comic series titled F*** Patrol. So he says, hey, will you guys visit, quote, RJ in his hotel room and convince him not
否则我就要在网上摧毁海王。所以，与此同时，约翰尼·德拉马（Johnny Drama）在动漫展上，他有一个非常好的朋友，一位成人电影明星，杰西·简（Jesse Jane），由杰西·简饰演。她正在推广她名为《性巡逻》（F*** Patrol）的虚假漫画系列。所以他说，嘿，你们能去拜访一下，引用，R.J.在他的酒店房间，并说服他不要
to write a bad review of Aquaman? And because of her love of Vincent, she's like, yeah. And her and two of her pals in very very interesting outfits uh-huh and knock on the door and RJ is like whoa whoa and guess what does rain have a love scene with three women I need to ask him about it I need to ask him about it because they go in there they shut the door we don't know what happens, but I wonder if there was ever a scene of anything happening. Like, was there a scene that didn't make the episode? I don't know.
写关于海王的差评吗？因为她对文森特的爱，她就像，好的。她和她的两个伙伴穿着非常非常有趣的服装，嗯哼，敲门，R.J.就像，哇，哇，你猜怎么着，雷恩和三个女人有爱情戏吗？我需要问他，我需要问他，因为她们进去了，她们关上了门，我们不知道发生了什么，但我怀疑是否曾经有任何事情发生的场景。就像，是否有没进入那一集的场景？我不知道。
But then, of course, he writes, you know, Aquaman glowing review. So there you go, Rain. Rain, I have questions. I have questions for you. I will be texting you later. I really wish I knew this before Rain sent in his audio clips because I feel like the audio clips would have more. They would have anything to say about this. When I was listening to your description of this episode, it became
但然后，当然，他写了，你知道，海王的好评。所以就是这样，雷恩。雷恩，我有问题。我有问题要问你。我稍后会给你发短信。我真的希望在雷恩发来音频片段之前我就知道这一点，因为我觉得音频片段会有更多。如果他有任何关于这个的话要说。当我听你对这一集的描述时，它变得
very clear to me why I didn't watch Entourage. That and I feel good about that. I feel good that I didn't watch it. And I feel like yeah, that good call. There you go. Rainn Wilson as RJ Spencer on Entourage. I kind of want to see just that episode. Maybe just rain scenes. I just fast forwarded to rain scenes. You don't really need to see anything else from it. That was some shade. And so now we can get into the episode. Jan is visiting unexpectedly and discovering Movie Monday.
非常清楚，为什么我没看《明星伙伴》。那，而且我觉得那很好。我觉得我没看它很好。而且我觉得是的，那个好主意。就是这样。雷恩·威尔森饰演《明星伙伴》里的R.J.斯宾塞。我有点想看那一集。也许只是雷恩的场景。我只是快进到雷恩的场景。你真的不需要看其他的。那是一些讽刺。现在我们可以进入这一集了。简意外地来访，发现了电影星期一。
Yeah. And guess what? Not everyone approves of Movie Monday, Jenna. No, Angela, you do not approve. I do not approve. It is me.. No, Angela, you do not approve. I do not approve. It is me. I will own it. I do not approve. And then Angela is so sneaky. When Jan comes in, she like points to the conference room like, Mm-hmm, tattletale.
是的。你猜怎么着？不是每个人都赞成电影星期一，珍娜。不，安吉拉，你不赞成。我不赞成。是我……不，安吉拉，你不赞成。我不赞成。是我。我会承认。我不赞成。然后安吉拉太狡猾了。当简进来时，她就像指着会议室，嗯哼，告密者。
She is. But Angela, at 1 minute 49 seconds, where are you sitting for this talking head? You're by a window and there's a plant? Where are you? Oh, I know where I am because there's a deleted scene that's not in here where Dwight has to come find me. Michael's like, go get Angela, right? And Dwight's like, why me? He plays this really coy, it's like sort of a hilarious performance of like, well, I don't know where she is.
她是。但安吉拉，在1分49秒，你坐在哪里做这个独白？你在窗边，有一株植物？你在哪儿？哦，我知道我在哪儿，因为有一个删除的场景不在这里，德怀特必须来找我。迈克尔就像，去把安吉拉叫来，对吧？德怀特就像，为什么是我？他演得非常害羞，这是一种滑稽的表演，就像，好吧，我不知道她在哪里。
Yes, why are you asking me for Angela? And then he goes and finds her and he knows exactly where she is. I am sitting behind the vending machine, sort of squished up in the wall behind the plant on a chair. And I am needle pointing a foot like a cat. I'm needle pointing a cat. And that's where this talking head is. Yes and there is that window that goes from the break room into that little
是的，你为什么要找我要安吉拉？然后他去找到了她，他确切地知道她在哪里。我坐在自动售货机后面，挤在植物后面的墙上，坐在椅子上。我在针绣一只猫的脚。我在针绣一只猫。这就是这个独白的地方。是的，那扇窗户从休息室通向那个小
hallway. Into the hallway and there's a big plant there and that's where I'm sitting. It was driving me nuts. There's a whole scene that happens there that didn't make it in the episode where I start plotting. That's the first seed I plant is that you wouldn't do this as a manager. You wouldn't waste everyone's time like this. I see. All while needle pointing a face of a cat. I love that. All right, we have a fan catch. Angela Beth Boss says, When Jan walks in, she puts her bag and coat down on the chair in front of Michael's office.
走廊。通向走廊，那里有一株大植物，我就坐在那里。这让我快疯了。那里发生了一整场没进入那一集的场景，我开始策划。那是第一颗我种下的种子，即你作为经理不会这样做。你不会这样浪费大家的时间。我明白了。所有这些都在针绣一只猫的脸时。我喜欢那个。好吧，我们有一个粉丝花絮。安吉拉·贝丝·博斯（Angela Beth Boss）说，当简走进来时，她把包和外套放在迈克尔办公室前的椅子上。
But when Angela points to the conference room and the camera cuts back to Jan, she's holding her coat and she's just now putting it down in the chair. Good catch, Beth Boss. Way to go. There's some Duangela sass in this episode as we know, and two of my favorite Duwayne Angela sass lines are coming up around two minutes 39. Angela's telling Dwight to meet her in the kitchen,
但当安吉拉指着会议室，镜头切回简时，她拿着外套，她现在才把它放在椅子上。好花絮，贝丝·博斯。干得好。这一集里有一些“杜安吉拉”（Duangela）的俏皮话，正如我们所知，我最喜欢的两句“杜安吉拉”俏皮话出现在2分39秒左右。安吉拉告诉德怀特在厨房见她，
and she says that Jan is gonna be peeved off. Jan is peeved off. And then Dwight in his talking head said, "'Yeah, Jan's really been bitching out on him ever since he broke up with her. I'm like, what is up with Angela? They're like kind of cursing. They're being a little tacky, Jenna.
她说简会很生气。简确实很生气。然后德怀特在采访中说：“是的，自从和她分手后，简一直对他抱怨不断。”我在想，安吉拉怎么了？他们好像在骂人。他们有点俗气，珍娜。
Oh, you think so? I think they're being a little tacky. They've hit their limit, Angela. They can't take it anymore. They can't take the inefficiency. They can't take it anymore. They can't take the inefficiency. They can't take, you know what happens? It's like for all these years, they've been separately stewing over all of this,
哦，你这么认为吗？我觉得他们有点俗气。他们已经到了极限了，安吉拉。他们受不了了。他们受不了这种低效率。他们受不了了。他们受不了这种低效率。他们受不了，你知道发生了什么吗？就像这些年来，他们一直各自为政，对这一切感到不满，
but now that they're together, you know how that happens in a couple? Yeah. Now they're kind of like mind melding. Yeah. Well, Ange, I love this scene with Dwight and Angela in the kitchen. It's around 2 minutes, 42 seconds.
但现在他们在一起了，你知道情侣之间会发生这种事吗？是的。现在他们有点像思想融合了。是的。好吧，安吉，我喜欢德怀特和安吉拉在厨房里的这场戏。大约在2分42秒。
You guys are back to back again, not facing one another. Angela's telling Dwight that he's the one who should be writing the office, and he should talk to Jan about it. We had a fan question from Evan Warburton. He says, Angela, did it make it easier or more difficult to film a scene when the characters are back to back? Because I know that Rainn and Angela did quite a few scenes like this. Like, did it make it easier to stay in character because you
你们又背靠背了，没有面对面。安吉拉告诉德怀特，他才是那个应该写办公室报告的人，他应该和简谈谈。我们收到了埃文·沃伯顿的一个粉丝提问。他说，安吉拉，当角色背靠背时，拍摄这场戏是更容易还是更困难？因为我知道雷恩和安吉拉拍过不少这样的戏。比如，这是否让你更容易保持角色状态，因为你
didn't have to make eye contact? What was it like? Tell us Angela. Well, I'll tell you this. The biggest thing about these scenes that I remember was timing because you cannot see the other person speaking. So, you know, you don't respond quite the same way because you want to make sure they finish their sentence or sort of whatever they're doing. They're emoting, right? Whatever their thing is. So I remember the first time we did it, there were probably more pauses because we wanted to sort of make sure we had the give and take because naturally when you talk to someone, you're reading their face.
不需要进行眼神交流？感觉如何？告诉我们，安吉拉。嗯，我告诉你。关于这些戏，我记得最深的是时机，因为你看不到对方在说话。所以，你知道，你的反应不会完全一样，因为你要确保他们说完句子，或者确保他们正在做的事情。他们在表达情感，对吧？无论他们要做什么。所以我记得我们第一次拍的时候，停顿可能更多，因为我们想确保我们有互动，因为自然地，当你和某人交谈时，你在读他们的脸。
And so it was sort of just like acting off of someone's voice as well. Like all of my reacting was in listening. I think in some ways it made us more thoughtful performers because we couldn't face the other person and we had to really listen to them and react off the last thing they said. Did it make it hard to improvise? Oh, for sure.
所以这就像是根据对方的声音来表演。我所有的反应都在倾听中。我认为在某些方面，这使我们成为了更深思熟虑的表演者，因为我们无法面对对方，我们必须真正倾听他们，并根据他们说的最后一句话做出反应。这让即兴表演变得困难吗？哦，当然。
I remember really being conscious of not improvising any lines within a written scene and anything that I did improvise came at the very end, when I knew I wouldn't be stepping on anything Rain said. So most of my improv in these scenes, if it made it in was something I said as I was leaving or at the very beginning. That makes sense.
我记得我非常注意不在剧本场景中即兴发挥任何台词，我所做的任何即兴发挥都是在最后，当我确定不会打断雷恩说的任何话时。所以我在这些场景中的大部分即兴表演，如果被保留下来的话，都是我在离开时或在最开始时说的。这很有道理。
So yeah, so they have this scene in the kitchen, Angela storms out, she's furious. She tells Dwight he needs to grow a pair, right? And a talking head. See what I mean? Jenna, she has had it. And on growing a pair, let's move to Stanford. Let's grow a pair and move to Stanford.
所以，是的，他们在厨房里有这场戏，安吉拉冲了出去，她很愤怒。她告诉德怀特他需要硬气一点，对吧？还有一个采访。看到我的意思了吗？珍娜，她受够了。关于硬气一点，让我们转到斯坦福。让我们硬气一点，搬到斯坦福去。
All right, so what's happening at Fancy Stanford, Jenna? They're playing Call of Duty. Jim explains that what started as a team building exercise has now turned into this super competitive game of Call of Duty, which keeps interrupting their workday. He mentions, this is where Jim brings up Pam. He's like, yeah, we didn't really play video games and Scranton. But you know, we did other things like Pam and I would hum a high-pitched tone and try to convince Dwight that he needed to see an ear doctor.
好吧，那么在高级的斯坦福发生了什么，珍娜？他们在玩《使命召唤》。吉姆解释说，最初作为团队建设练习的游戏现在变成了一场超级竞争的《使命召唤》游戏，这不断打断他们的工作日。他提到，这就是吉姆提起帕姆的地方。他说，是的，我们在斯克兰顿不怎么玩电子游戏。但你知道，我们做了其他事情，比如帕姆和我，我们会哼出一个高音调，并试图说服德怀特他需要去看耳科医生。
Pam called it pretendinitis. Oh, Jim. Jim, Jim, Jim, Jim, Jim. He's just thinking of Pam. Oh, Lordy. But then back in Scranton, Angela, Pam is not talking about Jim. She's signing for a package. She's gotten a delivery.
帕姆称之为“假装炎”。哦，吉姆。吉姆，吉姆，吉姆，吉姆。他只是在想帕姆。哦，天哪。但回到斯克兰顿，安吉拉，帕姆不是在谈论吉姆。她正在签收一个包裹。她收到了快递。
Listen, she went on a date last, the week for a package. She's gotten a delivery. Listen, she went on a date last, the week before, right? She went on a date. Now she's getting some new clothes. With the help of Kelly Kapoor, before we really dive into this scene, you guys, four minutes, 36 seconds, is Mindy wearing a side ponytail?
听着，她上周去约会了，为了一个包裹。她收到了快递。听着，她上周去约会了，对吧？她去约会了。现在她买了一些新衣服。在凯莉·卡普尔的帮助下，在我们真正深入这场戏之前，伙计们，4分36秒，明迪是不是扎着侧马尾？
Come on. You're bringing up her side ponytail. What about her bangs? I mean... She has bangs. She has bangs, but she has an extension-filled side ponytail. There's a lot happening with her hair. I don't have a sting for it, but it would go, full Mindy! Yeah. Why don't we have a full Mindy sting? We really need to get on that.
得了吧。你提到了她的侧马尾。那她的刘海呢？我是说……她有刘海。她有刘海，但她扎着一个充满接发的侧马尾。她的头发有很多戏。我没有为此准备音效，但它应该是“全套明迪！”是的。为什么我们没有“全套明迪”的音效？我们真的需要搞一个。
Someone make this a full Mindy sting. Someone do it. Well, this leads to a very famous office line. Fashion show! Fashion show! Fashion show at lunch! Yes! Yes! Guys, that is 100% scripted. That was in the script. That was not an improv. It was written exactly like that. Mindy delivers it perfectly. We had a lot of fan questions about this scene. People mostly wanted to know, did I get to pick out the outfits that Pam gets in her online shopping spree? And also, were there more things in the box besides that single shirt that she gets out
有人把这个做成“全套明迪”的音效吧。有人去做。好吧，这引出了一句非常著名的办公室台词。时装秀！时装秀！午餐时装秀！是的！是的！伙计们，那是100%照剧本演的。那在剧本里。那不是即兴表演。它就是那样写的。明迪表演得非常完美。我们有很多关于这场戏的粉丝提问。人们主要想知道，帕姆在网上购物狂欢中买的衣服是我选的吗？还有，除了她拿出来并在后来厨房里穿的那件衬衫之外，盒子里还有别的东西吗？
and wears later in the kitchen? Okay, yes. We had a big wardrobe fitting about what would these outfits be, and there were more things in the box, but I'll have to tell you they were basically that same shirt, but there was a turquoise one. There was a lot of jewel toned shirts that looked almost identical to that one shirt that you see. And that was kind of part of the joke. Because have you done that when you're shopping? You're like, I'm going to get a whole new wardrobe. And then you just kind of go to the store and buy the same pair of pants in three colors.
好的，是的。我们进行了一次大型服装试穿，讨论这些衣服会是什么样，盒子里确实还有其他东西，但我得告诉你，它们基本上是同一件衬衫，但有一件是绿松石色的。有很多宝石色调的衬衫，看起来几乎和你看到的那件衬衫一模一样。这其实是笑话的一部分。因为你在购物时做过这种事吗？你会说，我要买一整套新衣柜。然后你只是去商店买了三件同款不同色的裤子。
Oh my gosh, I always do that. I find like one shirt I like and then buy it in three colors. And people are like, hey, I have you worn that? Oh, I is that it? And I'm like, no, it's the same shirt. It's the same shirt. Yeah. That was kind of what happened with Pam's, like, redesign of her wardrobe was that she managed to find one thing that she was willing to take a chance on and then bought it in different colors. Here's what I remember about that, Jenna.
天哪，我总是那样。我找到一件我喜欢的衬衫，然后买三种颜色。人们会说，嘿，你穿过那个吗？哦，是那件吗？我说，不，这是同一件衬衫。这是同一件衬衫。是的。帕姆的“衣柜重塑”就是这样，她设法找到了一件她愿意尝试的东西，然后买了不同颜色的。关于这一点，我记得的是，珍娜。
Because all of us saw each other every day pretty much in the same wardrobe right? Yeah. Whenever one of our characters did get anything slightly different we were like hey so I remember our reactions to your red fancy blouse so similar to our characters minus the gross pervy stuff but we were all like oh my god you look so great oh my god you look amazing pervy stuff, but we were all like, Oh my God, you look so great. Oh my God, you look amazing. And you're like, Oh, it's just the wardrobe for the scene. It did feel like that whenever we got a slightly fancier hairdo or a slightly cooler outfit. Yeah, everyone noticed. We all talked about it. We're like, wow, look at that. Wow. So now we're back at Stanford, my lady.
因为我们每天几乎都穿着同样的衣服看到对方，对吧？是的。每当我们的角色穿上稍微不同的衣服时，我们就会说，嘿，所以我记得我们对你那件红色时髦衬衫的反应，和我们的角色非常相似，减去那些恶心的变态行为，但我们都说，天哪，你看起来太棒了，天哪，你看起来太美了。而你会说，哦，这只是这场戏的服装。每当我们换上稍微时髦一点的发型或稍微酷一点的衣服时，确实感觉就是那样。是的，每个人都注意到了。我们都谈论它。我们说，哇，看那个。哇。所以现在我们回到斯坦福了，女士。
Back at Stanford. And Andy is getting ticked off at gym for killing the wrong soldiers in Call of Duty. Yes, and did you notice that four minutes and 59 seconds, there is still a blue sticky note on Jim's computer that says smile? No, I didn't notice. That's a great catch.
回到斯坦福。安迪因为吉姆在《使命召唤》里杀错了士兵而对吉姆发火。是的，你注意到在4分59秒，吉姆的电脑上还有一张蓝色的便利贴写着“微笑”吗？不，我没注意到。那是个很棒的发现。
Yeah, it's still there. Fan question from Shelby Hagan. How was Call of Duty chosen as the game that was played in the Stanford branch? Thank you so much for your question, Shelby. We actually got so many questions about Call of Duty, and this seemed like the perfect one to get us started. As you guys know, Jenna and I were not in those scenes at Stanford.
是的，它还在那儿。来自谢尔比·哈根的粉丝提问。为什么选择《使命召唤》作为斯坦福分部玩的游戏？非常感谢你的提问，谢尔比。我们确实收到了很多关于《使命召唤》的问题，这似乎是一个让我们开始的完美问题。如你们所知，珍娜和我没有参与斯坦福的那些场景。
That's right. So Shelby, I reached out to a lot of people to get you the real deal on all things Call of Duty. Angela, I got all the scoop from our line producer Kent Sabornak. I texted with our editor Dean Holland and Andy Bernard himself, Ed Helms. Lainey, that is a serious deep dive. I like it, I like it. I deep dived, I really did.
没错。所以谢尔比，我联系了很多人，为你打听关于《使命召唤》的一切真相。安吉拉，我从我们的制片主任肯特·萨博纳克那里得到了所有内幕。我和我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德以及安迪·伯纳德本人，埃德·赫尔姆斯发了短信。莱尼，那真是深入挖掘。我喜欢，我喜欢。我深入挖掘了，真的。
Okay, so what'd you find out? All right, so Kent told me that after we wrapped season one of the show, the post-production guys moved to some offices in Venice to edit the episodes. And while they were there, Kent just, for whatever reason, just on a whim whim installed Call of Duty on everyone's computers, just so they could blow off steam during edit sessions.
好吧，你发现了什么？好吧，肯特告诉我，在我们拍完第一季后，后期制作人员搬到了威尼斯的一些办公室去剪辑剧集。当他们在那里时，肯特出于某种原因，一时兴起在每个人的电脑上安装了《使命召唤》，只是为了让他们在剪辑期间放松一下。
And then when we moved to our new stages for season two, he did it again, but this time he also installed it on all of the writers' computers. And that is when the editors and the writers started playing one another. I remember is when the editors and the writers started playing one another. I remember this because our editors and writers were in the same building. They were over where the warehouse is, right? And the writers were upstairs and the editors were downstairs. And sometimes I would go over there at lunch because I was friends with Claire Scanlon, one of our
然后当我们搬到第二季的新摄影棚时，他又做了一次，但这次他还把它安装在了所有编剧的电脑上。那时剪辑师和编剧开始互相比赛。我记得这个，因为我们的剪辑师和编剧在同一栋楼里。他们在仓库那边，对吧？编剧在楼上，剪辑师在楼下。有时我会在午餐时过去，因为我和克莱尔·斯坎伦是朋友，她是当时我们的
editors at the time. And I would walk in the editing bay and they were all like, get down And I would walk in the editing bay and they were all like, get down, over here. I was like, what is happening? I remember going up to the writers room and seeing the same thing. They had this big conference table in the writers room and they would have all their computers in a circle. And then some people had little offices and then some people would be around this conference room table. And it was the same thing.
剪辑师之一。我会走进剪辑室，他们都说，趴下，到这边来。我说，发生了什么事？我记得去编剧室也看到了同样的情况。他们在编剧室里有一张大会议桌，他们会把所有的电脑围成一个圈。然后有些人有小办公室，有些人就在会议桌周围。情况是一样的。
They did exactly like what Stanford did. They would turn off the lights. Yeah. And they would have this elaborate match going on. Oh my gosh, they were so into it. Well, I guess Greg Daniels was particularly obsessed. In fact, our editor, Dean Holland, told me that the very first time he met with Greg to start editing an episode, within about 10 minutes, Greg said, have you ever played Call of Duty?
他们做得和斯坦福一模一样。他们会关掉灯。是的。他们会进行一场精心策划的比赛。天哪，他们太投入了。好吧，我想格雷格·丹尼尔斯特别着迷。事实上，我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德告诉我，他第一次和格雷格见面开始剪辑一集时，大约10分钟内，格雷格就说，你玩过《使命召唤》吗？
And Dean was like, yeah. And he said, Greg left the room and started a 20-person game. Like within 10 minutes. How perfect that Greg was the person that directed this episode, because he loves Call of Duty. I know. He loves it. I don't think that was a mistake. No.
迪恩说，玩过。他说，格雷格离开了房间，开始了一场20人的游戏。就在10分钟内。格雷格亲自执导这一集真是太完美了，因为他喜欢《使命召唤》。我知道。他喜欢它。我不认为那是个错误。不。
No. All right. Well, I have a little runner-up question for you, Jenna. Okay. So Evan Warburton wrote in and said, hey, I need to point this out. Jim is apparently horrible at Call of Duty at the Stanford branch in this episode, but in the episode email surveillance, you can see in the background of the scene at 20 minutes, eight seconds,
不。好吧，我有一个小小的后续问题给你，珍娜。好的。埃文·沃伯顿写信说，嘿，我需要指出这一点。吉姆在这一集的斯坦福分部里玩《使命召唤》显然很糟糕，但在“电子邮件监控”那一集里，你可以在20分8秒的背景中看到，
that Toby is playing Call of Duty on Jim's TV. Remember at the barbecue, Jenna? Yes, yes. So, and then also in Jim's bedroom at 15 minutes, 52 seconds, you can see an expansion pack of Call of Duty on Jim's desk. Come on, someone please explain. All right, yes. you can see an expansion pack of Call of Duty on Jim's desk. Come on, someone please explain.
托比正在吉姆的电视上玩《使命召唤》。记得在烧烤会上吗，珍娜？是的，是的。然后还有在吉姆的卧室里，15分52秒，你可以看到吉姆的桌子上有一个《使命召唤》的扩展包。得了吧，有人请解释一下。好吧，是的。
All right, yes. We actually had a lot of people write in about this glitch. I went to that time code, 15 minutes 52 seconds. There it is. There is an expansion pack Call of Duty. Here's how this went down, guys. Kent told me that the writers had a card up on the wall in the writer' room all through
我们确实有很多人写信询问这个漏洞。我去了那个时间码，15分52秒。就在那儿。有一个《使命召唤》扩展包。事情是这样的，伙计们。肯特告诉我，编剧们在整个第二季期间都在编剧室的墙上贴着一张关于《使命召唤》故事情节的卡片。
season two about a possible Call of Duty storyline. But they couldn't really ever figure out how to put it in. And they had originally thought about doing something, an email surveillance. And if you remember, Angela, we did actually shoot some scenes where people were playing Call of Duty during Jim's party. Yeah. But it wasn't a storyline. Yeah. It wasn't a storyline. where people were playing Call of Duty during Jim's party. But it wasn't a storyline. Yeah, it wasn't a storyline.
但他们一直没想出怎么把它放进去。他们最初考虑在“电子邮件监控”里做点什么。如果你记得的话，安吉拉，我们确实拍了一些人们在吉姆的派对上玩《使命召唤》的场景。是的。但那不是故事情节。是的。那不是故事情节。
It was just something people were doing at the party kind of in the background, but that was there in the script. Yeah, and it didn't really though go anywhere. So finally, when they went to Stanford, they wrote this full plot line. And they had to just live with the fact that there had been this tiny appearance of Call of Duty
那只是人们在派对背景中做的事情，但那是剧本里有的。是的，而且它确实没去向任何地方。所以最后，当他们去斯坦福时，他们写了这个完整的情节。他们不得不接受这样一个事实，即《使命召唤》之前有过一次小小的露面，
earlier, but they so wanted a full Call of Duty story that they just went with it. I was like, it's worth it. They're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever, whatever, email surveillance. We've got to have a real episode that features Call of Duty. You know what I did for myself? The way I made it make sense is that
但他们太想要一个完整的《使命召唤》故事了，所以他们就这么做了。我当时想，这值得。他们说，是的，是的，是的，随便吧，随便吧，“电子邮件监控”。我们必须有一集真正以《使命召唤》为特色的剧集。你知道我为自己做了什么吗？我让自己理解的方式是，
Jim had roommates. You know, he had roommates who probably played it. Maybe it was never his thing. You know, maybe he stole the expansion pack and put it in his room to make his roommate stop playing. Maybe that's why it's in his room, along with his guitar that he never plays. Okay, Jenna and Suzy, come on. Come on. So I listened to the DVD commentary for this episode, and Jenna Rashida said that she got lessons on how to play Call of Duty from the writers.
吉姆有室友。你知道，他有室友可能玩过它。也许这从来不是他的爱好。你知道，也许他偷了扩展包并把它放在自己的房间里，好让他的室友停止玩。也许这就是它在他房间里的原因，还有他从不弹的吉他。好吧，珍娜和苏西，得了吧。得了吧。所以我听了这一集的DVD评论，珍娜·拉希达说她从编剧那里得到了如何玩《使命召唤》的课程。
As soon as she got the job, they started teaching her how to play Call of Duty, which just cracks me up. And John actually had something really sweet to say in the commentary. He said that going to the Stanford branch, all of those actors had never worked together before, right? And that playing Call of Duty with one another was actually a really fun icebreaker to get
她一得到这份工作，他们就开始教她怎么玩《使命召唤》，这让我笑死了。约翰在评论中确实有一些非常甜蜜的话要说。他说去斯坦福分部，所有那些演员以前从未一起工作过，对吧？而和彼此玩《使命召唤》实际上是一个非常有趣的破冰方式，让
to know everyone. You know, Ed and I traded some messages and he said the same thing. He said they all played with the writers and it was really, really fun. And he told me that they also played for real on set. Yeah. They were really playing during those scenes. and it was really, really fun. And he told me that they also played for real on set. Yeah. They were really playing during those scenes. And then when they would cut, they would just keep playing.
大家互相了解。你知道，埃德和我交换了一些信息，他也说了同样的话。他说他们都和编剧一起玩，真的非常非常有趣。他还告诉我，他们在片场也玩真的。是的。他们在那些场景中真的在玩。
He said it was a lot of fun and people got super, super into it. I have a little FOMO. I have a little FOMO about it because I feel like we would have had fun with that at Scranton. I mean, all we- See, we knew they were having fun over there without us.
他说这很有趣，人们超级超级投入。我有一点错失恐惧症。我有一点错失恐惧症，因为我觉得我们在斯克兰顿也会玩得很开心。我是说，我们——看，我们知道他们在没有我们的情况下玩得很开心。
We knew us, dang it. All we were doing was playing solitaire. Exactly. Oh, Jenna, did you get any scoop in your deep dive on who was the best player? Who was our best player? Well, I don't think any of the actors were very good. Oh, really? Ed said he didn't remember anyone being particularly great, including himself. Kent told me that he was the best player when they started, but that during the editing phase of season one when they were in Venice,
我们知道，该死。我们所做的只是玩纸牌游戏。没错。哦，珍娜，你在深入挖掘中得到关于谁是最佳玩家的消息了吗？谁是我们最好的玩家？嗯，我不认为演员们玩得很好。哦，真的吗？埃德说他不记得有谁特别厉害，包括他自己。肯特告诉我，他们刚开始时他是最好的玩家，但在第一季剪辑阶段他们在威尼斯时，
co-producer Angie Hamilton was the best, hands down. Wow. But then, see, it sort of depends on who you ask because Dean told me that during season two, he and writer Mike Schurr were the best. They were at the top of the leaderboard. He said they got so into it that they took it over to Parks and Rec when they moved over there and they played it every day on Parks and Rec. And Kent did concur that Mike and Dean left as champions, but he also said
联合制片人安吉·汉密尔顿是最好的，毫无疑问。哇。但后来，看，这取决于你问谁，因为迪恩告诉我，在第二季期间，他和编剧迈克·舒尔是最好的。他们处于排行榜的顶端。他说他们太投入了，以至于当他们搬到《公园与游憩》时，他们把游戏也带过去了，他们每天都在《公园与游憩》里玩。肯特确实同意迈克和迪恩是冠军，但他也说
that their assistant editor Mike Zurer was pretty great. All right. All right. Well, I think those were fantastic questions. Thank you so much, Shelby and Evan. All right. Well, I think those were fantastic questions. Thank you so much, Shelby and Evan. All right. So now at five minutes, 12 seconds, we're in the parking lot. Dwight, you know, he's kind of psyching himself up like he does that. We've seen him do this before,
他们的助理剪辑师迈克·祖勒也很棒。好吧。好吧，我认为这些问题太棒了。非常感谢你们，谢尔比和埃文。好吧，现在在5分12秒，我们在停车场。德怀特，你知道，他正在像往常一样给自己打气。我们以前见过他这样做，
like in the stairwell. And in the DVD commentary, rain mentioned that that run that he does in the parking lot that Paul Lieberstein showed him exactly how he wanted that run done. So I picture these two guys just running back and forth. he does in the parking lot that Paul Lieberstein showed him exactly how he wanted that run done. Really? I picture these two guys just running back and forth.
比如在楼梯间。在DVD评论中，雷恩提到他在停车场跑的那一段，保罗·利伯斯坦确切地告诉他想要那种跑法。所以我脑海中浮现出这两个家伙跑来跑去的样子。
It makes me laugh thinking about it. And then Dwight calls Jan. And he says, hey, I need to talk to you. It's not safe here. He's crouching down. People are walking about. Kevin's around. And he tells her to go to the Liz Claiborne outlet at exit 40
想到这个我就想笑。然后德怀特给简打电话。他说，嘿，我需要和你谈谈。这里不安全。他蹲了下来。人们走来走去。凯文在附近。他告诉她去40号出口的利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯，
because he knows that she likes buying those blouses from Liz Claiborne. Yeah, he says he'll meet her there. Yeah, I'll meet you at the Liz Claiborne outlet. He says, go in and shop. I'll meet you there. And she says, how do you know I like their blouses? And he says, it's part of my job to know. And then she has that great line where she's like,
因为他知道她喜欢买利兹·克莱本的那些衬衫。是的，他说他会在那里见她。是的，我会在利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯见你。他说，进去逛逛。我会在那儿见你。她说，你怎么知道我喜欢他们的衬衫？他说，了解这些是我的工作的一部分。然后她说了那句很棒的台词，她说，
it literally is not part of your job. Yeah, he's like, it's absolutely not part of your job to know this. And then Dwight's like, noted. How long has Dwight been tracking her clothes? I feel like Dwight is the tracker, the way we track things on the podcast. That's what Dwight was doing of like everyone in the office. He's got some real creepy notebooks. Oh, he has meticulous creepy notes. the way we track things on the podcast. That's what Dwight was doing of like everyone in the office. He's got some real creepy notebooks. Oh, he has meticulous creepy notes.
这字面上根本不是你的工作。是的，他说，了解这些绝对不是你的工作。然后德怀特说，记下了。德怀特跟踪她的衣服多久了？我觉得德怀特是那个跟踪者，就像我们在播客里跟踪事情一样。这就是德怀特在办公室里对每个人做的事情。他有一些真正令人毛骨悚然的笔记本。哦，他有细致入微、令人毛骨悚然的笔记。
Lady, I had to do a deep dive the minute he said exit 40. I had to know, are there Liz Claiborne outlets at exit 40? So I can tell you all the outlets in Pennsylvania. Did you go there, lady? Did you go there? Okay, I did not go there Angela because remember when I said earlier that our fans got real into some deep dives on this? We had multiple people write in about Liz Claiborne outlets and Exit 40. Jenny Aguirre wrote in to say there is no Exit 40 according to three Google Map suggestions from Scranton to New York. Did you find that Angela? No No exit 40? Yeah, I couldn't find an exit 40 either. OK, well, Michaela Brock said that the only Liz Claiborne store near Scranton is in Ramsey, New Jersey, which is about an hour
女士，他一说40号出口，我就不得不深入挖掘。我必须知道，40号出口有利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯吗？所以我可以告诉你宾夕法尼亚州所有的奥特莱斯。你去那儿了吗，女士？你去那儿了吗？好吧，我没去那儿，安吉拉，因为记得我刚才说我们的粉丝对这些深入挖掘很感兴趣吗？我们有多个人写信询问利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯和40号出口。珍妮·阿吉雷写信说，根据从斯克兰顿到纽约的三条谷歌地图建议，根本没有40号出口。你发现了吗，安吉拉？没有40号出口？是的，我也没找到40号出口。好吧，米凯拉·布洛克说，斯克兰顿附近唯一的利兹·克莱本商店在新泽西州的拉姆齐，大约需要一个小时
and 45 minutes away on the quickest route. But Elizabeth M said that Jan has said she's been driving an hour, supposedly to New York City, which would not be on the way to this Liz Claiborne outlet that is in New Jersey, and it would actually add 25 miles to her drive. Well, I want you to know, when I was in junior high, my favorite perfume was the Liz Claiborne perfume. Oh! It came in a little like triangle, you know,
45分钟的路程。但伊丽莎白·M说，简说她已经开车一个小时了，据说是去纽约市，那不会是在去这个位于新泽西州的利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯的路上，而且实际上会给她的车程增加25英里。好吧，我想让你知道，我在初中时，我最喜欢的香水就是利兹·克莱本香水。哦！它装在一个小三角形里，你知道，
and you took the top off. I loved Liz Claiborne perfume. So I would have been very excited about this Liz Claiborne outlets. And my mom loves the outlets. We have had to pull off on the side of the road. Like she would say to my dad, Bill, there's the outlets. Here we go.
你把盖子拿掉。我喜欢利兹·克莱本香水。所以我对这些利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯会非常兴奋。我妈妈喜欢奥特莱斯。我们不得不把车停在路边。就像她会对我爸爸说，比尔，那是奥特莱斯。我们走吧。
Oh, my mom loves the outlets. There is a Carter's outlet. There's a Baby Gap outlet. My mom shops the outlet and she sends just like bags of clothes to me for my kids from these outlets. It's the best. Guys, loving on the outlets. So you can go to outletlocator.com and type in your state and find out your outlets. So this is what I found. There are three outlets in Pennsylvania for Liz Claiborne. There's one in Lancaster, one in Hershey and one in Redding. And then lady, when we get to it later, I'll let you know what outlet locator.com says about Ann Taylor. I'll hold on to that. I'll hold on
哦，我妈妈喜欢奥特莱斯。有一个卡特奥特莱斯。有一个婴儿盖普奥特莱斯。我妈妈在奥特莱斯购物，她会从这些奥特莱斯给我孩子寄来一袋袋衣服。这是最好的。伙计们，爱上奥特莱斯。所以你可以去outletlocator.com输入你的州，找到你的奥特莱斯。所以我发现了这个。宾夕法尼亚州有三家利兹·克莱本奥特莱斯。一家在兰开斯特，一家在赫尔希，一家在雷丁。然后女士，当我们稍后讲到时，我会让你知道outletlocator.com关于安·泰勒说了什么。我会保留那个。我会保留
to it. Oh yes. Many people wrote in about Ann Taylor. So we'll put a pin in that. So, and then, you know, Dwight gets off the phone and he tells Michael he has an emergency crown that he has to get put in. Michael's like, oh, that, you know, that sucks. And he said, yeah, it's a new dentist
那个。哦，是的。很多人写信询问安·泰勒。所以我们会把那个先放一放。然后，你知道，德怀特挂了电话，他告诉迈克他有一个紧急牙冠需要安装。迈克说，哦，那，你知道，那太糟糕了。他说，是的，这是一个新的牙医，
that is three hours away. And off Dwight goes. Well, Michaela Brock wants you to know that if Dwight goes to a Liz Claiborne store in New Jersey, he would have been gone longer than three hours because driving time alone would have been three hours. He wouldn't have even had time to meet with Jan. Guys, we did not think this through. Our writers did not go to OutletLocator.com when they wrote this scene. They did not. Well,
在三个小时路程之外。然后德怀特就走了。好吧，米凯拉·布洛克想让你知道，如果德怀特去新泽西州的利兹·克莱本商店，他离开的时间会超过三个小时，因为光是车程就需要三个小时。他甚至没时间见简。伙计们，我们没考虑周全。我们的编剧在写这场戏时没有去OutletLocator.com查。他们没有。好吧，
wherever he went, Dwight is now in a parking lot with Jan. And she has done some shopping. She's got some bags. She's got some bags. I have a question for you, Jenna, since I know you have the scripts. There is this line that Dwight says to Jan, and I feel like it's rain improving when he said, did you get a new blouse, halter top, camisole, Teddy? Is that rain improvising?
无论他去了哪里，德怀特现在和简在停车场。她买了一些东西。她有一些袋子。她有一些袋子。我有一个问题问你，珍娜，既然我知道你有剧本。德怀特对简说了这句台词，我觉得那是雷恩即兴发挥的，他说，你买了新衬衫、吊带背心、吊带衫、泰迪熊内衣吗？那是雷恩即兴发挥的吗？
Yeah. All of that was scripted except for teddy. Teddy. There you go. I knew one of them. He threw in teddy at the end. I knew one of them had to be rain. Aw, you would be friends with Kate Lonergan who wrote in that same question, lady. Oh, hi Kate. All right. So now Dwight and Jan have a meeting at a nearby restaurant. And this is where Dwight really turns on Michael and he starts to campaign to take over the office. He campaigns and grosses me out at the same time. I mean I am impressed with his no-look poor. A no-look poor of syrup is no joke. Lady that was scripted!
是的。除了“泰迪熊内衣”之外，所有这些都是剧本写的。泰迪熊内衣。给你。我知道其中一个。他在最后加了泰迪熊内衣。我知道其中一个一定是雷恩。哦，你会和凯特·朗格根成为朋友，她写了同样的问题，女士。哦，嗨，凯特。好吧。所以现在德怀特和简在附近的餐馆开会。这就是德怀特真正背叛迈克的地方，他开始竞选接管办公室。他竞选，同时让我感到恶心。我是说，我对他的“盲倒”印象深刻。不看杯子倒糖浆可不是开玩笑的。女士，那是剧本写的！
I mean that was amazing. I thought the same thing. I looked it up in the script and there is a stage direction that says, here's what it says, Dwight takes the syrup as he talks without breaking eye contact with Jan and pours it over everything on his plate. Amazing. Amazing. We did get some questions, Lady, about his eating of the waffles and pancakes, which
我是说那太棒了。我也这么想。我在剧本里查了一下，有一个舞台指示是这样写的，这是它写的：德怀特在说话时拿起糖浆，在不与简进行眼神交流的情况下，把它倒在盘子里的所有东西上。太棒了。太棒了。女士，我们确实收到了一些关于他吃华夫饼和煎饼的问题，这
is also delightful. That was not scripted. Rain just ate how he wanted to eat. Casey Halpin asked, how much of those waffles and pancakes did Rain have to eat in that scene? Was he really eating them or did he have a spit bucket? Well, guess what? Rainn Wilson answers this eating question.
也很令人愉快。那不是剧本写的。雷恩只是想怎么吃就怎么吃。凯西·哈尔平问，雷恩在那场戏里必须吃多少华夫饼和煎饼？他是真的在吃，还是有一个吐痰桶？好吧，猜猜怎么着？雷恩·威尔逊回答了这个吃的问题。
All right, let's play the clip, Sam. Here's what Rain has to say. Here's my deal about eating scenes. I love to eat during eating scenes. I love, and if you'll see Dwight, he'll always, when there's an eating scene, he's got a mouth full of food to me. It's really funny He's just wolfing down big bites of food and talking while eating and it's disgusting But it just felt really really right for the character and I also like it as an actor So this was a joy to cover and I love that stage direction of Dwight's eyes never leave jams as he covers his plate entirely in syrup and Melora Harden is such a joy to act with because she's so specific and so underplayed and
好吧，让我们播放片段，萨姆。听听雷恩怎么说。这是我关于吃戏的原则。我喜欢在吃戏中吃。我喜欢，如果你看到德怀特，他总是，当有吃戏时，他嘴里塞满了食物。对我来说，这真的很有趣。他只是狼吞虎咽地吃大块食物，边吃边说，这很恶心，但对于这个角色来说，这感觉真的非常非常对，而且作为演员我也喜欢它。所以这是一种享受，我喜欢德怀特在把盘子完全覆盖上糖浆时，眼睛从未离开简的舞台指示，梅洛拉·哈登是一个非常令人愉快的合作演员，因为她非常具体，而且非常低调，
No matter what you throw at her. She's right there. She's totally game and always in character All right. So there you have it guys. Rain was really eating. He was really eating, not spitting them out. Rain did not use a spit bucket. I have done a lot of scenes with Rain Wilson and I can tell you the guy goes for it. He goes for it across the board, whatever it is. So if he was going to eat a waffle, by golly, he's going to eat that waffle. Well thank you Rain. Thank you for sending in that clip. We've got more guys coming up. This is also the scene lady where at the end of the scene, he tells Jan there's an Ann Taylor
无论你给她什么。她就在那里。她完全配合，总是处于角色状态。好吧。所以你们有了，伙计们。雷恩是真的在吃。他真的在吃，没有吐出来。雷恩没有用吐痰桶。我和雷恩·威尔逊拍过很多戏，我可以告诉你，这家伙是来真的。他全力以赴，无论是什么。所以如果他要吃华夫饼，天哪，他会吃掉那个华夫饼。好吧，谢谢雷恩。谢谢你寄来那个片段。伙计们，我们还有更多内容。这也是女士，在场景结束时，他告诉简附近有一家安·泰勒
store nearby and he knows that she likes the earrings. Melora's performance as Jan is so great. She's like, where is it? Yeah, she's like, yeah, where is it? I do actually. I do want to look at the earrings. Well, Michaela Brock wants you to know that while there are 20 Ann Taylor stores around the Scranton area, the nearest one to a Liz Claiborne is about 16 minutes away. Now, Jenny added, Angela, I told these, everyone deep dived on this.
商店，他知道她喜欢那里的耳环。梅洛拉作为简的表演太棒了。她说，它在哪儿？是的，她说，是的，它在哪儿？我确实。我确实想看看耳环。好吧，米凯拉·布洛克想让你知道，虽然斯克兰顿地区周围有20家安·泰勒商店，但离利兹·克莱本最近的一家大约在16分钟路程之外。现在，珍妮补充说，安吉拉，我告诉过这些，每个人都对此进行了深入挖掘。
There is an outlet mall roughly an hour away from Scranton. I think this is the one you're talking about. It's on the I-80 East route. It's called the Crossings Premium Outlet. Did you find this one? Well, I can tell you on outletlocator.com, there is an Ann Taylor outlet in Lancaster as well, and also one in Hershey as well.
离斯克兰顿大约有一个小时路程的奥特莱斯购物中心。我想这就是你说的那个。它在I-80东线上。它叫“十字路口高级奥特莱斯”。你找到这个了吗？好吧，我可以告诉你，在outletlocator.com上，兰开斯特也有一家安·泰勒奥特莱斯，赫尔希也有一家。
So if you were at Liz Claiborne, you could hit Ann Taylor at both of those outlets. And then there's another one in Tannersville and Pottstown. But there's no Liz Claiborne at those. No, but you have a Liz Claiborne crossover at Hershey and Lancaster. Well, Jenny was noting that at the Crossings Premium outlet, there is also Billy's Pocono Diner.
所以如果你在利兹·克莱本，你可以在那两个奥特莱斯都去安·泰勒。然后坦纳斯维尔和波茨敦还有另一家。但那里没有利兹·克莱本。没有，但在赫尔希和兰开斯特你有利兹·克莱本的交叉点。好吧，珍妮指出在“十字路口高级奥特莱斯”，还有比利波科诺餐厅。
So they serve breakfast and it is possible that that's where they were eating. And then Jan could pop over to that Ann Taylor. According to Kentopedia, however, for anyone who wants to know, this was shot in Toluca Lake, California at Patty's Diner. Famous Patty's Diner. I've eaten there, and so I can tell you with great authority that Rainn Wilson was eating delicious pancakes and waffles at Patty's. All right, well, we've got to get back to the Scranton branch because the shiitake is about to hit the fan.
所以他们供应早餐，他们可能就是在那里吃的。然后简可以去那家安·泰勒。然而，根据肯特百科全书，对于任何想知道的人，这一幕是在加利福尼亚州托卢卡湖的帕蒂餐厅拍摄的。著名的帕蒂餐厅。我在那里吃过，所以我可以很有权威地告诉你，雷恩·威尔逊在帕蒂餐厅吃的是美味的煎饼和华夫饼。好吧，我们得回到斯克兰顿分部，因为香菇（shitake，谐音shit）要爆发了。
But before we do that, let's take a little break. Yeah, let's take a break. I'm going to refill my coffee. You refill your coffee. I'm probably going to go pee. Overshare? Maybe. That's where I'm at.
但在我们做那件事之前，让我们休息一下。是的，让我们休息一下。我要去续杯咖啡。你去续杯咖啡。我可能要去尿尿。过度分享？也许吧。这就是我的现状。
You always pee during our breaks. It's kind of like, remember when you gave me grief about saying, do you want to hear a summary? Do you want to hear a fast fact? When you know I'm going to say them anyway. It's kind of like, you don't have to tell us that you're going to pee on the breaks anymore, because we all just know. We just know. You have a tiny bladder. I have a tiny bladder. I'm a tiny person. I do as well. Listen, I pee on every break too. I just haven't been talking about it. But well, I am hell on a road trip.
你总是在我们休息时尿尿。这有点像，记得你因为我说“你想听总结吗？你想听快速事实吗？”而责怪我吗？当你明明知道我无论如何都会说它们的时候。这有点像，你不需要再告诉我们你要在休息时尿尿了，因为我们都知道。我们只是知道。你有一个小膀胱。我有一个小膀胱。我是一个小个子。我也一样。听着，我也在每次休息时尿尿。我只是没说出来。但好吧，我在公路旅行中简直是个灾难。
If we can ever road trip again, you don't want me in the car with you because I need to know where I can pee. I'm that person. Where am I gonna pee? Yeah. Where am I gonna pee? Where am I gonna pee? Get me an iced tea. Where am I gonna pee? I know that's the... I drink my way through a road trip, just sodas and water and snacks, and then also pee seven times. Maybe we are perfect partners for road tripping. Because we would just know, we're gonna pee, and we're gonna... Yeah, but we'd have to sync up.
如果我们能再次公路旅行，你不会想让我和你一起在车里的，因为我需要知道我在哪里可以尿尿。我就是那种人。我会在哪里尿尿？是的。我会在哪里尿尿？我会在哪里尿尿？给我一杯冰茶。我会在哪里尿尿？我知道那是……我在公路旅行中喝个不停，只是汽水、水和零食，然后还要尿七次。也许我们是公路旅行的完美搭档。因为我们只会知道，我们要尿尿，然后我们会……是的，但我们得同步。
We would need someone to be the alpha bladder, and someone to be the beta bladder. Now you do sound like Dwight. All right, let's take a break. The best adventures start with the right vehicle and end with memories that last a lifetime. We know that's important to you. It's important to us too. Toyota, for what matters most. We know that's important to you. It's important to us too.
我们需要一个人成为“阿尔法膀胱”，另一个人成为“贝塔膀胱”。现在你听起来像德怀特了。好吧，让我们休息一下。最好的冒险始于合适的车辆，并以终生难忘的回忆结束。我们知道这对你很重要。这对我们也同样重要。丰田，为了最重要的事。我们知道这对你很重要。这对我们也同样重要。
Toyota, for what matters most. than ever, whether it's reviving old memories with AI upscaling or seamless hands-free control with universal gestures. This isn't just television, it's a whole new vision because it isn't just about what's on, it's about who's watching. Learn more about Samsung Vision AI televisions at Samsung.com. All right, we're back. Jan has called Michael to tell him he needs to get a hold of his employees and do a better job because they are going behind his back to her, right? Yes, and Michael cannot believe that Dwight would try to turn his ex-lover-ish against him. One of my favorite lines, and it's probably because of how earnestly Steve says it as
丰田，为了最重要的事。比以往任何时候都多，无论是用AI升级重温旧回忆，还是通过通用手势进行无缝免提控制。这不仅仅是电视，这是一个全新的愿景，因为它不仅仅关乎播放什么，更关乎谁在观看。在Samsung.com了解更多关于三星Vision AI电视的信息。好吧，我们回来了。简给迈克打了电话，告诉他他需要控制好他的员工，做得更好，因为他们正在背着他找她，对吧？是的，迈克无法相信德怀特会试图把他的前情人变成他的对立面。我最喜欢的台词之一，可能是因为史蒂夫作为
Michael, is when Jan calls him and he says, you were at the dentist. Oh yes. Michael thinks that she randomly ran into Dwight where he was getting his crown removed. They're like, no, Michael, it's all a lie. Yes. Oh yes. I love it so much. Well, Angela then we move into the kitchen where Pam is modeling her new top for Kelly and Phyllis.
迈克说得如此真诚，是当简给他打电话时，他说，你在牙医那里。哦，是的。迈克认为她偶然遇到了德怀特，当时他正在拔牙冠。他们说，不，迈克，这全是谎言。是的。哦，是的。我太喜欢它了。好吧，安吉拉，然后我们进入厨房，帕姆正在为凯莉和菲利斯展示她的新上衣。
This is the fashion show. And then Roy walks in with a soda. And he is, oh, I Pam's like taking his breath away right here. Poor Roy. Also, what is there? Not a vending machine in the warehouse? Come on. In that whole warehouse, there's not a vending machine. You've got to come up to the office three times for a soda. Well, you know what? That line was improv by Mindy.
这就是时装秀。然后罗伊拿着汽水走了进来。他，哦，我帕姆在这里让他屏住了呼吸。可怜的罗伊。还有，那里有什么？仓库里没有自动售货机吗？得了吧。在整个仓库里，没有自动售货机。你得为了汽水三次来到办公室。好吧，你知道吗？那句台词是明迪即兴发挥的。
Oh, way to go, Mindy. Isn't that so good? Yes. She had that same thought, right? Like, oh, third soda of the day. In the script, as he's walking out the kitchen door, she was just supposed to say, awkward. Oh, nice. All right, so when we go back to Stanford, Josh puts the game on hold. He calls Andy and Jim into the conference room.
哦，干得好，明迪。那不是很好吗？是的。她有同样的想法，对吧？比如，哦，今天第三杯汽水。在剧本里，当他走出厨房门时，她本应该只说，“尴尬”。哦，不错。好吧，所以当我们回到斯坦福时，乔什暂停了游戏。他叫安迪和吉姆进会议室。
Jim is like, oh, finally we're doing work. No, no, he wants to doing work. No, no. He wants to devise a strategy for the game. So speaking of improvisation, Ed had a bunch of improv at the end of the scene. So when he calls Jim a saboteur that was improvised, that was not in the script, and then when he says all that stuff where he's like, I am going to kill you for real.
吉姆说，哦，终于我们要工作了。不，不，他想工作。不，不。他想为游戏制定策略。所以说到即兴表演，埃德在场景结束时有一堆即兴表演。所以当他称吉姆为破坏者时，那是即兴的，那不在剧本里，然后当他说所有那些话时，比如，我真的要杀了你。
This game is over. I am really going to kill you for real. This game is over. I am really going to shoot you. Like all of that, that was, that was Ed improv. Well, in the DVD commentary, John said that this scene was maybe one of the hardest that he had to work not to break. He said that Chip and Ed, Chip who plays Josh,
游戏结束了。我真的要杀了你。游戏结束了。我真的要射杀你。就像所有这些，那是，那是埃德的即兴表演。好吧，在DVD评论中，约翰说这场戏可能是他最难忍住不笑的场景之一。他说奇普和埃德，奇普扮演乔什，
were just crushing it. And he said he was having the toughest time so I kind of want to rewatch it to watch his face. But lady I have a little trivia about Rain and Chip, Chip who plays Josh. Oh what is it? Okay so did you know that Rain and Chip were in an NBC pilot in 1999. It was called The Expendables. Now, Rain mentioned this in the DVD commentary and I had to do a deep dive.
简直太棒了。他说他当时最难忍住，所以我有点想重看一遍来观察他的脸。但女士，我有一个关于雷恩和奇普的小花絮，奇普扮演乔什。哦，是什么？好吧，你知道雷恩和奇普在1999年出演过一部NBC试播集吗？它叫《敢死队》。现在，雷恩在DVD评论中提到了这一点，我不得不深入挖掘。
I was like, what? It sounds like a superhero fantasy type show. Ready? I looked it up online. This is what IMDB had to say about it. The Expendables was an NBC pilot. It was about a scientist who creates two indestructible life-like robots. They have an affinity for television, particularly Starsky and Hutch. Their unexpected development of emotions prompts a need for them to help people. Chip played the character Ram. Rain played the character Newman.
我当时想，什么？听起来像是一部超级英雄奇幻剧。准备好了吗？我在网上查了一下。这就是IMDB对它的评价。《敢死队》是一部NBC试播集。它是关于一位科学家创造了两个坚不可摧、栩栩如生的机器人。他们对电视有亲和力，特别是《警界双雄》。他们意外产生的情感促使他们需要去帮助人们。奇普扮演角色拉姆。雷恩扮演角色纽曼。
Now, are those characters both the robots who developed feelings? They're robots. They're robots. Okay. Yeah, and Rain said it was so bad, but that he and Chip became friends, and Rain was one of the people that suggested Chip
那么，这两个角色都是产生了感情的机器人吗？他们是机器人。他们是机器人。好的。是的，Rain说那部戏很烂，但他和Chip成了朋友，而且Rain是建议Chip出演Josh的人之一。
for the role of Josh. That is some good, I would call that a tidbit and a deep dive. That's a deep tidbit. Can we go to Scranton now? We probably should. This is one of my favorite all time scenes of all time on any television show ever made ever. This is one of my favorite bits ever.
那真是不错，我会称之为花絮和深度挖掘。那是一个深度的花絮。我们现在可以去斯克兰顿了吗？我们大概应该去了。这是我这辈子看过的所有电视剧中最喜欢的场景之一。这是我最喜欢的片段之一。
Crentus the dentist. Your dentist's name is Crentus. Maybe that's why he became a dentist. There is a deleted scene where Michael Scott, he's like Scott and he starts seeing what all would name with Scott. But he said none of them are occupations. Okay so in the script the Crentus dentist scene is word for word, you guys. There is nothing improvised about this scene. This was all written by Paul Lieberstein. Paul, you are a genius.
牙医Crentus。你牙医的名字叫Crentus。也许这就是他成为牙医的原因。有一个删减片段，迈克尔·斯科特，他就像斯科特一样，开始看所有能叫斯科特的名字。但他说了，没有一个是职业。好吧，剧本里的Crentus牙医场景是一字不差的，伙计们。这个场景没有任何即兴发挥。这全是保罗·利伯斯坦写的。保罗，你真是个天才。
It is perfection. And you're right, there's a deleted talking head. And then there is even more to this scene in the script that is deleted. So if you want to see like an extended version of this genius, please visit the deleted scenes. I love it so much. We asked Rain about it and he sent in this clip. Alrighty then, Office Ladies podcast, Jenna, Angela. Hi, it's me, Rainn Wilson.
这太完美了。你说得对，有一个删减的采访镜头。而且剧本里这个场景还有更多被删减的内容。所以如果你想看这种天才表演的加长版，请去看看删减片段。我太喜欢它了。我们问了Rain关于这件事，他发来了这段音频。好吧，Office Ladies播客，珍娜，安吉拉。嗨，是我，雷恩·威尔森。
Remember me? Vaguely. Everyone talks about the crentest scene has being so spectacular and i know that it's some of the funniest writing i think polybrysian wrote it in all of the office the dentist crentest and that jousting between me and michael but the scene afterwards where apprentice and that jousting between me and Michael. But the scene afterwards where Dwight and Michael play this chess game and Michael pretends to give up his position to Dwight is absolutely masterful.
还记得我吗？隐约记得。每个人都说Crentus那个场景非常精彩，我知道这是我认为保罗·利伯斯坦在《办公室》里写过的最有趣的剧本之一，那个牙医Crentus，还有我和迈克尔之间的那种交锋。但随后的场景，德怀特和迈克尔玩国际象棋，迈克尔假装把自己的位置让给德怀特，那绝对是大师级的。
And I think Steve is I mean, he's great in everything, but he just kills it. And it's so subtle and underplayed. And I love how Game of Thrones it is. I forgot that this whole episode is like these power plays and power ploys and who's going behind who's back. It's like Littlefinger and Valeris in Highgarden or whatever, I think I'm getting all the Game of Thrones names wrong, But in the
我觉得史蒂夫，我是说，他在什么戏里都很棒，但他在这里简直绝了。而且非常微妙，处理得很克制。我喜欢它那种《权力的游戏》的感觉。我忘了整集就像这些权力博弈和权谋，谁在背后搞谁。就像《权力的游戏》里的小指头和瓦里斯在高庭什么的，我想我把《权力的游戏》里的名字都搞错了，但在
Red Keep, all the maneuvering, you know, the Lannisters and backstabbing and loyalty and you don't know whose side who's on. And it's so fantastic. But the thing that gets me every time is that the reason it all falls apart is that Dwight insults the sea brain. And ultimately the sea bring is the hinge is the linchpin. And it all falls apart because of the sea brain. But this episode was so well written. I remember there's sometimes when you just are like, it's just best to sit back and play the lines and have fun with them as much as
红堡里，所有的权谋，你知道，兰尼斯特家族，背叛和忠诚，你不知道谁站在哪一边。这太棒了。但每次让我印象深刻的是，这一切崩溃的原因是德怀特侮辱了赛布林（Sebring）。最终，赛布林是关键，是枢纽。一切都因为赛布林而崩溃。但这一集写得太好了。我记得有时候你只是觉得，最好坐下来，照着台词演，尽可能多地从中获得乐趣。
possible. And I think this was one of those. And I often felt that way about Paul Lieberstein's writing. It's very specific and it was made worse through improvisation, not better. Sometimes the writing could benefit from some kind of actors bringing their mojo, but it was not that way with the coup. There you have it. You know I was screaming back at him even though he couldn't hear me because it was a recorded audio clip. I love that you brought up Littlefinger and Cersei And Cersei! And Game of Thrones! I love you so much! Because Reign, I love Game of Thrones too.
我想这就是其中之一。我经常对保罗·利伯斯坦的剧本有这种感觉。它非常具体，通过即兴发挥只会变糟，而不是变好。有时剧本可以从演员带来的某种魔力中受益，但《政变》那一集并非如此。就是这样。你知道我当时在对着他尖叫，尽管他听不见，因为那是录好的音频片段。我喜欢你提到小指头和瑟曦！还有《权力的游戏》！我太爱你了！因为雷恩，我也爱《权力的游戏》。
And I am Cersei. Angela is Cersei. In this episode, she's Cersei. All right. Well, Reign brought up the scene where they're in Michael's office and Michael turns the tables on Dwight and it all falls apart. And I have to agree in rewatching this, Crentus is so funny, but this dance between Steve and Rain and how they perform this scene, I think Rain is right. Like this is like,
我是瑟曦。安吉拉是瑟曦。在这一集里，她是瑟曦。好吧。嗯，雷恩提到了他们在迈克尔办公室的场景，迈克尔反将了德怀特一军，一切都崩溃了。我不得不承认，重看这一集，Crentus太搞笑了，但史蒂夫和雷恩之间的这种舞蹈，以及他们表演这个场景的方式，我觉得雷恩是对的。就像，
this is just like amazing acting and performance and writing that scene. It's all genius. It is all Amazing. I watched this episode three times and I could watch it again just for that scene It is so good and one of the things they talked about in the DVD commentary and I actually remember this is Greg really wanted to live in the pauses He wasn't afraid at all is Greg really wanted to live in the pauses. He wasn't afraid at all to let them take their time because he wanted it to have that kind of weight to it.
这简直是令人惊叹的表演和剧本。这一切都是天才之作。这一切都很棒。我看了这一集三遍，为了那个场景我还可以再看一遍。它太棒了。他们在DVD评论中谈到的一件事，我实际上记得，是格雷格真的很想活在停顿中。他一点也不害怕，格雷格真的很想活在停顿中。他一点也不害怕让他们花时间，因为他想让它有一种分量感。
And it just played so beautifully. We had a lot of questions about improvisation. I think because these scenes are so well performed, people think that they were improvised. So we had Carolyn Tuft wrote in about Michael's talking head, where he's talking about businesses like a jungle and he's the tiger. She wanted to know if Steve improvised any of that.
它演得太美了。我们有很多关于即兴表演的问题。我想因为这些场景表演得太好了，人们认为它们是即兴的。所以卡罗琳·塔夫特写信问关于迈克尔的采访镜头，他谈到商业就像丛林，而他是老虎。她想知道史蒂夫是否即兴发挥了其中的任何部分。
Nope, all scripted. Jerry Shue wrote in to say around 14 minutes, 40 seconds, Dwight calls Michael Mike. Yes. As they're getting ready to go out to the bullpen. And he said, I think this is the only time that Dwight ever called Michael Mike in the entire show. Would you happen to know why?
没有，全是剧本写的。杰瑞·舒写信说在大约14分40秒时，德怀特叫迈克尔“Mike”。是的。当他们准备去办公区时。他说，我想这是德怀特在整部剧中唯一一次叫迈克尔“Mike”。你知道为什么吗？
That was scripted. And it's scripted because Dwight thinks he has all the power now. So he is calling him Mike as a way to kind of demote him. Oh, yeah. No, he's doing that thing where you give people nicknames to sort of put them in their place. And it is so brilliant because he's also
那是剧本写的。剧本这样写是因为德怀特认为他现在拥有了所有权力。所以他叫他“Mike”是一种贬低他的方式。哦，是的。不，他是在做那种给别人起绰号来让他们各就各位的事情。这太聪明了，因为他也在
taking the power away. Michael's like, should we go out there? And he goes, when I'm ready, Mike. Yeah, it's brilliant. Well, when Michael does break the news to everyone, oh, Angela, you are so pleased. So pleased. Stanley has a lot of questions. Phyllis asked Michael what he plans to do. And Kevin is very concerned that Michael's going to lose his condo. Rain had a little something to say about this scene too, Angela, let's play this clip. Angela, your reaction, the tiniest hint of a smile,
夺走权力。迈克尔说，我们应该出去吗？他说，等我准备好了，Mike。是的，这太聪明了。好吧，当迈克尔向大家宣布消息时，哦，安吉拉，你太高兴了。太高兴了。斯坦利有很多问题。菲利斯问迈克尔他打算做什么。凯文非常担心迈克尔会失去他的公寓。雷恩对这个场景也有话要说，安吉拉，让我们播放这段音频。安吉拉，你的反应，那一丝极其细微的微笑，
of the Lady Macbeth smile that you give to White during when he's announcing the few of you that will be left during my reign. I'm going to lead you into the black with ferocity. Your little look there is fantastic, and Jenna, I love your to lead you into the black with ferocity. Your little look there is fantastic. And Jenna, I love your line about the vacuum cleaner being as capable a manager as Dwight. It was so much fun to shoot.
那种麦克白夫人的微笑，你在德怀特宣布“你们中剩下的少数人”时给他的。我要带着凶猛带领你们走向黑暗。你那小表情太棒了，还有珍娜，我喜欢你关于吸尘器作为经理和德怀特一样称职的台词。拍摄过程太有趣了。
It's so much fun to relive this with you guys. Maybe one day you'll have me actually back on the show again. Maybe the global pandemic has gotten in the way of that a little bit. I'm so glad for what you're doing with this show. I'm so happy, even though I haven't heard any of the episodes, and I probably never will, but I'm really happy for you because I like you both
和你们一起重温这些真是太有趣了。也许有一天你们会让我真的回到节目中。也许全球大流行稍微阻碍了这一点。我很高兴你们在做这个节目。我很高兴，尽管我还没听过任何一集，而且可能永远也不会听，但我真的为你们感到高兴，因为我喜欢你们俩，
and you seem like you're having fun. That's all I have to say. I love you both. Goodbye. Rain. You guys that is rain in a nutshell. He is our curmudgeon with a big heart and I love him so much. I love him so much. We're gonna figure this out and we're gonna get him on. Yes, rain. I love you. You tall, geeky man you. But this is true, Angela. I love how delighted your character is by this new shift in power. I love that when you're alone and you guys
而且你们看起来玩得很开心。这就是我要说的。我爱你们俩。再见。雷恩。伙计们，这就是雷恩的典型风格。他是我们那个刀子嘴豆腐心的老顽固，我太爱他了。我太爱他了。我们会想办法让他上节目的。是的，雷恩。我爱你。你这个又高又书呆子的男人。但这确实是真的，安吉拉，我喜欢你的角色对这种权力转移感到如此高兴。我喜欢当你独自一人时，你们
talk about it, he tells you that you can be in control of the women. And you're very pleased about that as well. Well, this now starts a series of talking heads, right? Cause everyone is reacting to this news. I am of course delighted. My character's delighted. So Phyllis has a talking head that I love so much, right? She says, maybe I'll quit. But if you look at the deleted scenes,
谈论这件事，他告诉你你可以控制女性。你也对此感到非常高兴。好吧，这开启了一系列的采访镜头，对吧？因为每个人都在对这个消息做出反应。我当然很高兴。我的角色很高兴。所以菲利斯有一个我非常喜欢的采访镜头，对吧？她说，也许我会辞职。但如果你看删减片段，
this goes on for a bit. And this is such a great line. Oh yes, Angela. Yes, yes, share this, share this. Okay, so she says that her fiance says after they get married she doesn't even need to work anymore, that her new job is going to be being Mrs. Bob Vance, the first lady of Vance Refrigeration. Yes, I loved that so much. It was so, so cute. And by the way, you see her play that role.
这持续了一会儿。这真是一句很棒的台词。哦，是的，安吉拉。是的，是的，分享这个，分享这个。好吧，她说她的未婚夫说他们结婚后她甚至不需要工作了，她的新工作将是成为鲍勃·万斯夫人，万斯制冷公司的第一夫人。是的，我太喜欢那个了。它太可爱了。顺便说一句，你看着她扮演那个角色。
Like, you see her take on being the First Lady of Vance Refrigeration as this relationship plays out over the series. Yeah, it's really fun to watch. And at 15 minutes, 50 seconds now, we have that Dwight tells Angela that she can be in charge of the women. Yes.
就像，你看着她随着这个关系在剧集中的发展，承担起万斯制冷公司第一夫人的角色。是的，看这个真的很有趣。现在在15分50秒，德怀特告诉安吉拉她可以负责女性员工。是的。
She's a little annoyed because I think she was like, we can do so many great things here. And he's like, there can only be one person in charge. But then as soon as he gives her a job that she gets to have control over people, she's okay with it. Okay, fine. Yeah. Fine. She accepts it.
她有点恼火，因为我想她当时想的是，我们可以在这里做很多伟大的事情。而他说，只能有一个人负责。但一旦他给了她一个可以控制别人的工作，她就没问题了。好吧，好吧。是的。好吧。她接受了。
I'll be in charge of the women. I remember doing the scene and I was kind of struggling with that final look and of what my expression was and Greg gave me direction. He said, Angela, I want you to imagine what you'll do to the other women. Oh my God. That was the look I had. That's amazing. That is amazing. So now we're back at Fancy Stanford and Karen is making fun of Jim's lack of Call of Duty skills, right? He's not very good at it, but she's just sort of smiling through it and just, she's clearly a little smitten. Sam?
我会负责女性员工。我记得拍那个场景时，我还在纠结最后的那个眼神，我的表情是什么，格雷格给了我指导。他说，安吉拉，我想让你想象一下你会对其他女性做什么。天哪。那就是我当时的表情。这太神奇了。这太神奇了。所以现在我们回到了高级斯坦福，凯伦在取笑吉姆缺乏《使命召唤》的技巧，对吧？他不太擅长，但她只是微笑着，显然有点迷恋。萨姆？
Flirty Karen. Yeah. I talked to my mom about it. I talked to Birdie Kinsey. Birdie said that's flirty Karen. Oh Angela, I love it so much. I love it that you made your mom say flirty Karen. It took a minute. I had to explain everything. She was like, what am I doing? And then I told her what Karen was up to and she said, well, she is being flirty. So this is flirty Karen guys. Karen is putting on the flirt. And this is what I was talking about in my fast fact.
调情的凯伦。是的。我和我妈妈谈过这件事。我和伯迪·金西谈过。伯迪说那是调情的凯伦。哦，安吉拉，我太喜欢了。我喜欢你让你妈妈说“调情的凯伦”。花了一点时间。我不得不解释一切。她说，我在做什么？然后我告诉她凯伦在做什么，她说，好吧，她确实在调情。所以这就是调情的凯伦，伙计们。凯伦在调情。这就是我在我的快速事实中提到的。
This is what got everybody very, very, very upset. Yes. And then on a side note, Rashida said in the DVD commentary that this was her audition scene. Oh, really? This was a scene she had to audition with. So she really knew this scene well. Well, I want you to know something. This is jumping ahead a little bit,
这就是让每个人都非常、非常、非常不安的事情。是的。顺便提一下，拉什达在DVD评论中说这是她的试镜场景。哦，真的吗？这是她必须试镜的场景。所以她真的很了解这个场景。好吧，我想让你知道一件事，这有点跳跃了，
but I just want to say to wrap up this storyline of the Jim Karen flirt, you know at the end of this, when Jim is packing up for the night and Karen's watching and he throws the fake grenade at her, this is now kind of like their first inside joke. That scene was not in the script. That was added later. We saw that Karen is kind of sweet on Jim a little bit, right?
但我只想说，为了结束吉姆和凯伦调情的这条故事线，你知道在这一集结束时，当吉姆收拾东西准备离开，凯伦在看着，他扔给凯伦那个假手榴弹，这现在算是他们的第一个内部笑话。那个场景不在剧本里。那是后来加进去的。我们看到凯伦有点喜欢吉姆，对吧？
In the scene you're talking about. But they wanted to see Jim give her a little helper. We wanted to see a little bit go her way and so they added that scene to show that there was a real connection between them. A playfulness if you will. Well it worked. We have to talk about the most uncomfortable groveling I've ever witnessed. And Rain in true Rain fashion, 18 minutes, 25 seconds, begins to beg. Beg Michael. And Michael is just watching him.
在你说的那个场景里。但他们想看吉姆给她一点帮助。我们想看到一点点进展，所以他们加了那个场景来表明他们之间有真正的联系。一种俏皮感，如果你愿意的话。好吧，它奏效了。我们必须谈谈我见过的最尴尬的卑躬屈膝。雷恩以他真正的雷恩风格，在18分25秒开始乞求。乞求迈克尔。而迈克尔只是看着他。
He gets on the ground. He kind of shugs his butt in the air. Then he lays flat on the ground. And then at 19 minutes, 11 seconds, Jenna, Jenna. The drool. Yeah. We got letters about the drool, Angela. It is so disgusting. It comes out, then he sucks it back in, then he kind of swallows it, then he hugs Michael hard. Yeah. Yeah, so all that stuff on the ground and the hugging and all of that, that was all scripted. The drool was just on the day. That was. Yeah. That was scripted drool. All rain. But rain is right in his little clip when he said it's the Sebring that breaks
他跪在地上。他有点把屁股撅在空中。然后他平躺在地上。然后在19分11秒，珍娜，珍娜。口水。是的。我们收到了关于口水的信，安吉拉。太恶心了。它流出来，然后他把它吸回去，然后他把它咽下去，然后他紧紧地拥抱迈克尔。是的。是的，所以地上所有的那些东西，拥抱，所有这些，都是剧本写的。口水只是当天发生的。那是。是的。那是剧本写的口水。全是雷恩。但雷恩在他的小片段里说得对，是赛布林让迈克尔崩溃的。
Michael. It is so brilliant when he's like, take it back. That's my car. Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh, my gosh. Well, you know when Michael tells Dwight to stand up and hug it out, bitch? We had a fan question from Kristen Bauer. She said, that line, hug it out, bitch,
这太聪明了，当他说，收回去。那是我的车。是的。是的。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道迈克尔告诉德怀特站起来拥抱一下，婊子？我们有一个来自克里斯汀·鲍尔的粉丝问题。她说，那句台词，“拥抱一下，婊子”，
is one of my favorite lines in the whole show, and it cracks me up. Who came up with that line? Well Kristen, this is a famous line from the show Entourage, which we set up earlier that Michael loves. Jeremy Piven's character Ari Gold would say it all the time. This was in the script. This was a callback.
是整部剧中我最喜欢的台词之一，它让我笑个不停。是谁想出那句台词的？好吧，克里斯汀，这是电视剧《明星伙伴》中的一句名言，我们之前提到过迈克尔很喜欢这部剧。杰里米·皮文的角色阿里·戈尔德经常会说这句话。这在剧本里。这是一个呼应。
And I got curious about it though Angela and I watched an interview last night with Jeremy Piven. And he said, he was talking about improvisation on the set of Entourage, and he said, we really did not improvise. We really didn't. He said it was very, very, very, very rare to improvise. But he said, occasionally they did. And the thing about improvisation he was saying was like,
但我对此感到好奇，安吉拉，我昨晚看了一个杰里米·皮文的采访。他说，他在谈论《明星伙伴》片场的即兴表演，他说，我们真的没有即兴发挥。我们真的没有。他说即兴发挥非常、非常、非常、非常罕见。但他确实说，偶尔他们会这样做。关于即兴表演，他说的是，
if you are in your character, then you will say something that your character would say. It's not about necessarily trying to be funny or clever. It's just about saying that next thing that your character would honestly say in the moment. He said that the line, hug it out bitch, was an improvisation. This famous line. he said it was crazy
如果你进入了你的角色，那么你就会说出你的角色会说的话。这不一定是为了变得有趣或聪明。这只是关于说出你的角色在当下会诚实说出的下一句话。他说那句“拥抱一下，婊子”是即兴发挥。这句名言。他说这太疯狂了，
because we rarely did it, but there was this scene that he was in and his character was trying to comfort another character and so he just improvised, let's hug it out bitch. Isn't that crazy? I love that that was an improvised line cause it sums up his character, his character Ari just perfectly.
因为我们很少这样做，但有一个他参与的场景，他的角色试图安慰另一个角色，所以他只是即兴发挥了“让我们拥抱一下，婊子”。这不是很疯狂吗？我喜欢那是一句即兴台词，因为它完美地总结了他的角色，他的角色阿里。
This is an amazing callback, which I love. As an improviser, I know, Rain, if you're listening, you're making fun of me right now, but as an improviser, I live for a callback. So I love that they set up entourage at the beginning and they bring this subtle reference back at the end. Well, now the episode really wraps up with Michael and Dwight.
这是一个了不起的呼应，我喜欢。作为一个即兴表演者，我知道，雷恩，如果你在听，你现在一定在取笑我，但作为一个即兴表演者，我为呼应而活。所以我喜欢他们在开头铺垫了《明星伙伴》，并在结尾带回了这个微妙的引用。好吧，现在这一集真的以迈克尔和德怀特结束了。
They're back in the conference room. They're watching a movie together. Angela, you walk by, you're not pleased, but listen, this're back in the conference room. They're watching a movie together. Angela, you walk by. You're not pleased. But listen, this is how it had to be. He chose Michael once again. I feel like Dwight is torn between Angela and Michael for years.
他们回到了会议室。他们一起看电影。安吉拉，你走过去，你不高兴，但听着，他们回到了会议室。他们一起看电影。安吉拉，你走过去。你不高兴。但听着，事情只能这样。他再次选择了迈克尔。我觉得德怀特多年来一直在安吉拉和迈克尔之间挣扎。
And then finally, it goes her way because he leaves. Well, Michael has his final talking head where he says, they hugged it out. He's still angry, so he did make Dwight stand in the middle of the office with a sign around his neck that says liar. And Dwight has to do Michael's laundry for a year, and that's where we leave it.
然后最终，事情朝着她的方向发展，因为他离开了。好吧，迈克尔有他最后的采访镜头，他说，他们拥抱了。他还是很生气，所以他确实让德怀特站在办公室中间，脖子上挂着一个写着“骗子”的牌子。德怀特必须为迈克尔洗一年的衣服，这就是我们结束的地方。
Before we wrap up, I have two little things to share with you guys. I did write in my journal about this episode, and I only wrote about one thing. All right, so Jenna, I wrote that I did a different talking head that didn't make it in the show and I said I thought it was so funny but maybe it was just too long.
在我们结束之前，我有两件小事要和你们分享。我确实在我的日记里写了关于这一集的内容，我只写了一件事。好吧，珍娜，我写道我做了一个不同的采访镜头，没有出现在节目中，我觉得它太搞笑了，但也许它太长了。
But Angela Martin says that she has a friend who has introduced her to a show called Star Trek. And in Star Trek, there is a guy named Spock and he's very honorable and brave and he stands up for what he thinks is right and she just wishes that someone in the office could be more like Spock. And I just thought it was really cute that it's a window into their lives that Dwight is teaching her about Star Trek and what she'd never heard of Star Trek.
但安吉拉·马丁说她有一个朋友向她介绍了一部叫《星际迷航》的剧。在《星际迷航》里，有一个叫史波克的人，他非常光荣和勇敢，他坚持他认为正确的事情，她只是希望办公室里有人能更像史波克。我只是觉得这很可爱，这是他们生活的一个窗口，德怀特在教她关于《星际迷航》的知识，而她以前从未听说过《星际迷航》。
Yeah. It's this little show. You probably have not heard of it called Star Trek. Here it is. So that deleted scene is not on the DVD extras, guys. I don't know where that lives, but I did a whole talking head about Star Trek. But there is a deleted scene I have to share with you, and I will leave you with this, Jenna. This is on the DVD extras. We find out that Creed sleeps under his desk four nights a week, and then he goes to his place in Toronto. Yeah. Yeah. I love that. What? When I was rereading the script, I read that and I actually remember Creed
是的。就是这个小节目。你可能没听说过，叫《星际迷航》。就是这样。所以那个删减片段不在DVD花絮里，伙计们。我不知道它在哪里，但我做了一个关于《星际迷航》的完整采访镜头。但有一个删减片段我必须分享，我会以此结束，珍娜。这在DVD花絮里。我们发现克里德每周有四个晚上睡在他的办公桌下，然后他去他在多伦多的住处。是的。是的。我喜欢那个。什么？当我重读剧本时，我读到了那个，我实际上记得克里德
shooting that and it was so funny. And I remember Paul cracking up while they were shooting that because he was so tickled by the idea that Creed slept under his desk. Yeah. This is why he doesn't have a refrigerator. Oh my God! He's never had his own. He's never had his own refrigerator.
拍摄那个场景，它太搞笑了。我记得保罗在拍摄时笑得前仰后合，因为他被克里德睡在办公桌下的想法逗乐了。是的。这就是为什么他没有冰箱。哦，天哪！他从来没有过自己的。他从来没有过自己的冰箱。
He's never had his own refrigerator because he sleeps under his desk. Four nights a week. I love it. And then what is his whole second life in Toronto? I am so intrigued. Guys, that was the coup. We love that you are sticking with us and continuing to listen to this podcast. It is a joy for us to make it.
他从来没有过自己的冰箱，因为他睡在办公桌下。每周四个晚上。我喜欢它。那他在多伦多的整个第二人生是什么？我太好奇了。伙计们，那就是《政变》。我们喜欢你们坚持和我们在一起并继续收听这个播客。制作它对我们来说是一种快乐。
Thank you again to Rainn Wilson for sending us your audio. If you want to hear more of Rainn's sexy voice, you can listen to his podcast, Metaphysical Milkshake with Rainn and Reza Aslan. Yes, they are discussing life's big human questions with heart, humor, and curiosity, stuff like life, death, love, fate, beauty, you name it. It is available on the Luminary Podcast platform. Rain, we're gonna get you back on here.
再次感谢雷恩·威尔森发给我们你的音频。如果你想听到更多雷恩性感的声音，你可以听他的播客，《Metaphysical Milkshake with Rainn and Reza Aslan》。是的，他们正在用心、幽默和好奇心讨论人类生活的大问题，比如生活、死亡、爱、命运、美，随你怎么说。它可以在Luminary播客平台上找到。雷恩，我们会让你再回来的。
We're gonna get glitchy up in here, Rain. We're gonna get glitchy up in here, Rain. We're gonna get glitchy up in here, Rain! Thank you so much for sending in your questions and your comments and your deep dives. We love you guys so much. We'll see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created
我们会让你在这里变得古怪起来，雷恩。我们会让你在这里变得古怪起来，雷恩。我们会让你在这里变得古怪起来，雷恩！非常感谢你们发来的问题、评论和深度挖掘。我们非常爱你们。我们下周见。感谢收听《Office Ladies》的第二杯。这一集最初是
in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna F Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis.
与Earwulf合作创作的。《Office Ladies》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。
Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Office Ladies》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。